GOOD AFTERNOON- WE
LIKE TO CALL TO ORDER THIS-
HEARING TODAY ON BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION AN INFORMAL
HEARING BY THE ASSEMBLY UTILITY
AND ENERGY COMMITTEE- I WOULD
LIKE TO CALL IT TO ORDER AND WE
WERE WE'RE HERE FOR THIS
INFORMATIONAL HERE TO DISCUSS
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
FOCUSING SQUARELY ON EFFORTS TO
DECARBONISE CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING. BUILDINGS BEFORE WE%
BEGAN I HAVE SOME HOUSEKEEPING
TO GO OVER WE ARE WEARING MASKS
AT ALL TIMES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO SOCIALLY DISTANCE WHILE
INSIDE THE CAPITOL WE HAVE VERY
LIMITED SPACE SO OUR PALACE
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
WE ENCOURAGE THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING THE CALL IN DURING THE
PUBLIC COMMENT SEGMENT OF THIS
HEARING THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON THE TV
SCREEN. ADDITION I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ORDER TO HEAR AS MUCH FROM THE
PUBLIC. WITHIN THE TIME AT A
TIME WE HAVE. WE WILL NOT
PERMIT CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT. OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS. AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE WILL BE REMOVED
FROM THE CHAMBER OR REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WE'RE HERE
ARE HOLDING THIS HEARING TODAY
AS CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD
GRAPPLES WITH A NEW CLIMATE
REALITY. THE U. N. RECENTLY
RELEASED THEIR REPORT AGAIN
ALERTING US THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
IS WIDESPREAD. AND RAPIDLY
INTENSIFYING AND WE EXPERIENCED
THIS FIRSTHAND AS VAST AREAS OF
OUR STATE AND COUNTY AND
COUNTRY BURN THE UN REPORT IS
GRAHAM BUT PROVIDES HOPE IF WE
ACT URGENTLY. WE MUST CONTNUE
TO PUSH FORWARD IN OUR FIGHT
AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE WITH
GREATER RESOLVE. THE STATE HAS
ALREADY ACTED URGENTLY TO CUT
EMISSIONS FROM MANY SECTORS
WE'RE BRINGING MORE RENEWABLE
ENERGY RESOURCES ONLINE AND
PAVING THE PATH FOR ZERO
EMISSION TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
OVER THE DECADES WE HAVE
PRIORITIZE ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN
BUILDINGS AND APPLIANCES
LEADING TO REDUCTIONS IN THE
BUILDING SECTOR. BUT THIS IS
NOT ENOUGH. TODAY OUR HEARING
WILL FOCUS ON WHAT MORE IS
NEEDED TO REDUCE EMISSIONS IN
THE BUILDING SECTOR WHICH
ACCOUNTS FOR ROUGHLY A QUARTER
OF OUR STATE'S GHG EMISSIONS.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE REDUCE
THESE EMISSIONS IN ORDER TO
MEET OUR STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS
WE WILL LOOK SPECIFICALLY AT
EFFORTS AND CHALLENGES AROUND
EXISTING BUILDINGS. WHICH ARE
DISTINCT FROM THE PROGRESS MADE
BY LOCAL AND STATE AUTHORITIES
TO ELECTRIFIED NEW CONSTRUCTION
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION TO MAKE. THE WORK
AROUND NEW CONSTRUCTION IS THE
FIRST STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS OLD. BY
TWENTY THIRTY ONLY A SMALL
FRACTION OF THE STATE'S
BUILDINGS WILL HAVE BEEN BUILT
WITH TODAY'S ENERGY EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS SO THE QUESTION TODAY
IS HOW CAN WE REDUCE EMISSIONS
FROM OUR EXISTING BUILDINGS AND
WHAT ARE THE CHALLENGES AHEAD
WE ARE HONORED TO HAVE YOUR
LOOSE RIVAS OF THE ASSEMBLY
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
JOIN US IN THE DISCUSSION TODAY
AND FOR HER CARE AND ATTENTION
TO THESE ISSUES. I WOULD LIKE
NOW TO WELCOME SURE RIVAS FOR
HER OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU
CHAIR HOLDEN AND TO YOUR TEAM
FOR PUTTING TOGETHER THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. ON
DECARBONISATION AND ALSO
PROVIDING MEMBERS OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
PARTICIPATE. AS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES I'M COMMITTED TO
MITIGATING THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. IMPROVING
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND EXPANDING
OUR RENEWABLE ENERGY PORTFOLIO
HE'S TO BE HERE BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT AND
TIMELY DISCUSSION. IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE OUR AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS WE HAVE TO TAKE BOLD
ACTIONS AND WE MUST BEGIN OR
CONTINUE TO DEPARTMENT
DECARBONIZE OUR EXISTING
BUILDING STOCK. WE DON'T HAVE
ANY TIME TO WASTE. CURRENTLY
AROUND A QUARTER OF OUR STATE'S
TOTAL GREENHOUSE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS COME FROM EXISTING
BUILDINGS AND THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE UPGRADES AND
IMPROVEMENTS IN THIS SECTOR
MUST BE MADE OUR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MUST BE IMPROVED OUR
SOURCES OF ENERGY THAT POWER
THESE BUILDINGS MUST BE CLEAN
AND RELIABLE. AND ARE ACTIONS
MRS STAIN ARE LONG TERM CLIMATE
GOALS. WERE WELL POSITIONED TO
MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS AND WE
SHOULD BE WE CANNOT ACHIEVE OUR
CLIMATE GOALS WITHOUT
DECARBONISING OUR EXISTING
BUILDINGS. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM THE PANELISTS ON
HOW WE SHOULD MOVE FORWARD AND
HOW MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
CAN BE HELPFUL IN OVERCOMING
ANY EXISTING CHALLENGES THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR- INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE. BUDGETARY WITH NOW
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
PANELISTS I'VE INVITED THE
PALACE TO KEEP THEIR REMARKS
BRIEF TO ALLOW MORE TIME FOR
QUESTIONS AFTER THE
PRESENTATIONS FIRST UP WE HAVE
COMMISSIONER ANDREW MCALLISTER
OF THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. WHO WILL PROVIDE
THE FOUNDATION FOR THIS YEAR
AND BY DISCUSSING FINDINGS FROM
THE INTERVIEW COMMISSION'S
RECENT AB THIRTY TWO THIRTY TO
REPORT. WELCOME COMMISSIONER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TERRY
HOLDEN HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR
ME OKAY WE CAN WE CAN HEAR YOU
JUST WELL THANK YOU EXCELLENT
EXCELLENT- SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU. FOR PUTTING THIS YEAR
TOGETHER IT'S VERY- GREAT TO
HEAR THAT THE RECOGNITION OF
THE ESSENTIAL NATURE OF OUR
EXISTING BUILDINGS- AND THE AND
HOW CRITICAL THEY ARE TO
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS I
WILL BE BRIEF THERE'S A LOT TO
COVER IN- IN THIS-
PRESENTATION- AND I WILL. TRY
TO DO IT AS EFFICIENTLY AS I
CAN SO- I WOULD LIKE TO- FIRST
HIGHLIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TWO THIRTY TWO- THAT IS A-
BILLS ASSEMBLY MEMBER TREATMENT
FROM SOME IN A FEW YEARS AGO
AND WE JUST THAT. TRANSMITTED
THE REPORT TO THE ASSEMBLY SO
I'M REALLY HAPPY TO HAVE IT
HIGHLIGHTED HERE TODAY. SO THE
MANDATES.OF THE ASSEMBLY BILL
I WAS TO- ASSESS THE POTENTIAL
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM OUR BUILDING
STOCK RIGHT LEAST 40% BELOW
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS BY.
TWENTY THIRTY. AND SO IT REALLY
BRINGS OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
PATHWAYS THAT WILL MAKE THE
STOP- ACHIEVABLE- WHAT PATHWAYS
WE NEED TO WALK DOWN. TO
ACTUALLY. MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND
IT IT SOME COSTA STRATEGY TO
COST ANALYSIS LOOK AT THESE
PATHWAYS WITH A CRITICAL EYE I
WOULD NOTE THAT- ANOTHER BILL
FROM MY TWO THOUSAND NINE NANCY
SKINNER- WHEN SHE WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AB TWO SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT WE'VE GOT SEVERAL
ITERATIONS OF THAT REPORTER
THAT PLAN WHICH IS AN EXISTING
BUILDING ENERGY EFFICIENCY
STRATEGY FOR THE STATE SO THAT
ALSO EXISTS WE'VE BEEN DRAWN ON
THAT. AS WELL SO BUILDINGS AND
BUILDING EMISSIONS AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY R. G. COMPLIMENTS
KEY COMPONENTS TO THIS
PROGRESS- AS YOU BOTH SAID
SYSTEM OUR BUILDINGS EMISSIONS
ARE 25% OF THE TOTAL IN THE
STATE. OF THOSE A LITTLE LESS
THAN HALF FOR DIRECT EMISSIONS
AND SO THAT IS ONSITE
COMBUSTION AND REFRIGERANTS
THERE A MINUTE AFTER AT EACH
BUILDING SO WE'VE LOOKED AT-
THE LEGISLATION SUGGEST BOTH OF
THOSE AS ORGANIZING PRINCIPLES
WE LOOK AT MOST OF BOTH OF
THOSE ASK BASED. ON THE
DIFFERENCES ACTUALLY- IMPORTANT
SO THAT ONE OF THE KEY
TAKEAWAYS THAT ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MAIN- CONTINUES TO
BE CRUCIAL- IS A KEY GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION STRATEGY AND IT'S
A STRATEGY TO. OPTIMIZE OUR OUR
OVERALL STATEWIDE PATHWAY TO
LOWER GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
AND SECONDLY HIGHLY EFFICIENT
ELECTRIC APPLIANCES IN
PARTICULAR HE POPS ARE CRITICAL
ESSENTIAL TO MEETING THE
STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY AND
CHRONICLES. LEVERAGING THE FACT
THAT THE ELECTRIC SYSTEM IS
ALREADY RAPIDLY DECARBONIZING
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO IN
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR OUR PS AND
SB ONE HUNDRED GOALS SO I'LL
JUST GO OVER SOME CONCLUSIONS
OF THE ASSESSMENT HERE- THE DO
WE REALLY THINK IT'S- I'M SORRY
THIS IS A- SORRY THIS HE'S GOT
MIXED UP SOMEWHERE I'M NOT SURE
HOW THAT HAPPENED BUT SORRY I
MUST HAVE PUT AN END TO THEIR
BY ACCIDENT SORRY ABOUT THAT NO
PRO- YEP. OKAY AREA SO WE HAD
AN THE REPORT ANALYZES SEVEN
BROAD STRATEGIES SO
ELECTRIFICATION IS REALLY
PRINCIPLE AMONG THEM AND YOU'LL
HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT FROM THE
OTHER SPEAKERS FOR SURE.
DECARBONISING ELECTRICITY
GENERATIONS MENTIONED THAT
ALREADY IT'S CRITICAL.
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES
CAN PROVIDE ADDITIONAL.
REDUCTIONS IN GREENHOUSE GAS- A
LOT OF THAT BUILDING CODES AND
THERE ARE LOTS OF STATE
PROGRAMS AND BEEN A PLACE FOR
SOME TIME ON THAT FRONT.
REFRIGERANT CONVERSION OVER TO
LOWER GWP GREEN GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL FOR DRESS AND
REDUCING LEAKAGE OF
REFRIGERANTS IS ALSO A KEY
STRATEGY AND WE ASSESS THE BAT
IN THE REPORT AN INTEGRAL WAY.
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AS A-
CONTINUES TO BE RIGHT THERE AT
THE TOP OF THE LOADING ORDER
AND IT'S. ALSO JUST JOB ONE
ACROSS THE ECONOMY WE S. THE
MAN FLEX AS A STRAY TO USE THE
CLEAN CLEAR MOLECULES AND CLEAN
CLEAN ELECTRONS PARTICULAR WHEN
THEY ARE AVAILABLE IN THE
BRIDGE YEAH AND- TRY TO AVOID
USING THE HIGHER CARBON
ELECTRONS. SO THAT TIME IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND INCREASING
IMPORTANCE TO UNDERPIN OUR
RELIABILITY OF OUR GREAT IN THE
STATE AND IS A KEY STRATEGY
PRETTY CARBONIZATION AS WELL.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S IN THE GAS
SYSTEM YOU'LL HEAR SOME ABOUT
AS WELL WE CAN'T SUBSTITUTE
SOME OF THOSE MOLECULES SO
EQUITY WE JUST HAVE TO FOCUS ON
EQUITY AND HAS TO BE A
FOUNDATION I'LL TALK ABOUT IT'S
JUST VERY VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT.
WHAT THAT MEANS BUT OUR
PROGRAMS REALLY NEED TO FOCUS
ON THE FOLKS WHO CAN'T AFFORD
THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE WILL-
THAT WILL BE- SUGGESTING AND-
WE- CAN'T CONVERT THE PROGRAM.
APPROACH TO START WITH UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES AND
ENCOURAGE THE MARKET TO SCALE
UP FROM THERE I THINK THAT'S A-
THAT THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL TO
GET THE TECHNOLOGIES AT SCALE
QUICKLY. IN THE SECTORS THAT
CAN LEAST AFFORD THEM AND USE
THAT AS A MARKET TRANSFORMATION
STRATEGY. A DIRECT COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT CANNOT EMPHASIZE THE
NEED TO WORK THROUGH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HELP THIS HAPPEN
ACROSS THE STATE. AND THEN
PROGRAM AND FINANCIAL
MECHANISMS TO HELP MAKE ALL
THIS HAPPEN. WE WILL NOT REACH
OUR CLIMATE GOALS UNLESS WE
LOOK AT IT THROUGH AN EQUITY
LENS THAT'S A KEY TECHNOLOGIES
HIGHLY EFFICIENT ELECTRIC
APPLIANCES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HE PUMPS FOR WATER AND SPACE
HEATING INDUCTION STOVES.
THAT'S NOT PART OF THE BUILDING
CODE BUT IT'S ALSO A KEY.
ENABLER IN SOME CASES WE'RE
HERE WHERE WE'RE SEEING ACT TO-
FULL EXPLICATION. AND ELECTRIC
CLOTHES DRYER SIDEKICK OR HEAT
PUMP CLOTHES DRIERS ARE NOT
QUITE THERE YET BUT THEY'RE
GETTING THERE. WILL BE A
SOLUTION IN THE FUTURE- WE HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT THE PANELING THE
PANELS AND WIRING. EXISTING
BUILDINGS THAT UPGRADE COST IS
NOT TRIVIAL- AND SOLAR IT WITH
STORAGE NOW TO IMPROVE ITS
FLEXIBILITY AND ITS
DECARBONISATION ACT. IS ALSO AN
ONGOING STRATEGY INCREASINGLY
WITH STORAGE AVAILABLE IN THE
MARKET. AND IT LOOKS LIKE
STABILITY AS I SAID FINANCING
MODELS WE DID THE NUMBERS ON
HOW MUCH HOW MUCH MONEY
ESSENTIALLY IT'S GOING TO COST
TO UPGRADE THE EXISTING
BUILDING STOCK ACROSS THE STATE
WERE TALKING. IN THE ORDER OF
THIRTY TO FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS. OVER THE COURSE OF.
THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS OR SO
THAT'S A SUSTAIN INVESTMENT
THAT WE NEED WE'RE NOT
SUGGESTING THAT. THE THE BILL
JUST ASSESSMENT RIGHT IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT A RECOMMENDATION BUT I
THINK THE- IDEA THERE WOULD BE
THAT WE HAVE TO LEVERAGE
PRIVATE INVESTMENT AND REALLY
DO THAT HANDSHAKE BUT PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS AND FIGURE
OUT WAYS. TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
IN PARTICULAR FOR LOW INCOME
AND RENTERS. WORKING WITH THOSE
SECTORS DIRECTLY TO FIND
SOLUTIONS FOR THEM. ONE
SOLUTION IS TERRACED ON BILL
FINANCING WHICH IS A REALLY
PRACTICAL SOLUTION THAT HELPS
NEWS OFF BALANCE SHEET. CAPITAL
BUT GETS THE RECOVERY ON THE
UTILITY BILL. SO THAT'S A
THAT'S A PROMISING SOLUTION
HAVING SOME ARE TRACK NOW IN IN
L. YEAH AND WE REALLY AS I SAID
NEED TO FOCUS ON PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS. SO I'M GONNA SHOW
COUPLE PICTURES- BASICALLY THE
TO THE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
BOTTOM LINE THAT'S THE ONSITE
EMISSIONS REDUCTION. GOAL OF
40% BELOW NINETEEN NINETY
LEVELS. AND IT REALLY ONLY OR
TO- SCENARIOS TO PASSWORD
STRATEGIES TO GET US THERE THE
AGGRESSIVE ELECTRIFICATION AND
EFFICIENT AGGRESSIVE
ELECTRIFICATION WASTE THE
LITTLE OF THE LIGHTER COLOR AT
THE TOP IS THE REFRIGERANTS
THAT ALSO NEED A SOLUTION TO
LOWER THEIR GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL- BUT THOSE TWO- AND
ALL THE STRATEGIES THAT ARE
LISTED ARE THE TWO THAT REALLY
GET US WHERE. TO GO TERMS OF
REDUCING BUILDING RELATED
EMISSIONS BOTH ONSITE AND
SYSTEM WIDE AND THEN THIS ONE
IS THE SAME SCENARIOS- AND IT
LOOKS AT THE COST PER TIME IS
THE RED LINE. AND THE SQUARES
AND THEN THE OVERALL COSTS AND
YOU KNOW YOU CAN SEE THOSE TWO
SCENARIOS. HAVE A COST PER TON
OF CARBON REDUCTIONS OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED FORTY DOLLARS IN THE
MID THIRTIES HIGH THIRTIES IN
TERMS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
INVESTMENT NEEDED. TO MAKE
THOSE HAPPEN HI ENERGY
EFFICIENCY IS A NEGATIVE COST
IT STILL WORKS REALLY WELL BUT
THE SCALE OF IT PRETTY
CARBONIZATION IS JUST NOT GONNA
GET US THERE SO WE SHOULD DO
THAT. BUT WE DO NEED TO FOCUS
ON. FUEL SUBSTITUTION WITH
CLEAN ELECTRICITY WHEREVER
POSSIBLE SO EXISTING BUILDINGS
THERE- LIST OF CHALLENGES HERE.
THE TIMING CONSUMER
FAMILIARITY. CAPITALS I
MENTIONED. SOME SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES PERHAPS THOSE ARE THOSE
WILL GET WORKED OUT- AND
ELECTRICITY AND NATURAL GAS
RATES WANT TO SURE INSURE
REALLY YOU SHOULD SEE SOME OF
THE BENEFIT IS THERE FOR RIGHT
THE CUSTOMER- SO- WITH THAT
SEAT SO HERE THE CONCLUSIONS-
SO WE NEED A LARGE SCALE
DEPLOYMENT LIKE. THIS NEARLY
CONSTRUCTION NEWLY CONSTRUCTED
BUILDINGS IF YOU SUGGESTED YOUR
HOLDEN HAVE THE LOWEST COST IN
ARE REALLY SORT OF THE EASIER
PART A PROBLEM. MAKING WILL
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE THAT FRONT-
SO EFFICIENCY AND PROVEN
ABILITY CLOSE ALIGNMENT WITH
THE CONVERSATION AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE SO. LARGE
INVESTMENTS IN THE EXISTING
BUILDINGS ARE NEEDED- AND
FURTHER LONG TERM. RELIABILITY
IMPACTS AS WELL NEED ASSESSING
ARE BOTH ON THE GAS SIDE AND
SIDE. THE BILL ASKS US TO DO.
THAT WE BEGIN THAT WORK WITH
THAT WILL CONTINUE NUMBER
CERTAINLY CAN IS A KEY PART OF
THIS A AS WELL AND THEN THE GAS
SYSTEM ROLE ANY INCENTIVES NEED
FURTHER REVIEWSUPPER GONNA
REALLY SHIFT. FROM ONE FIELD TO
ANOTHER WE HAVE TO CAREFULLY
PLAN THAT OVER TIME SOME ABOUT
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT. WOULD
PROBABLY OTHERS SPEAKERS AS
WELL AND PERHAPS THE DISCUSSION
SO EQUITY IS CRITICAL-
COLLABORATION A CAN'T EMPHASIZE
ENOUGH THIS IS A ALL HANDS ON
DECK AS BOTH OF YOU AS FOR THE
FUTURE HOLD. HI INJURY THAT
CENTS ADJUSTED- BROKE THEIR
WORKFORCE NEEDS LIKE THOSE WILL
COME ALONG WITH MARKET
EXPANSION- AND- I THINK THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO WORK
ALONGSIDE RESPONSES TO BUILDING
NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING HELP US-%
BERMAN AS ARE VARIOUS STATE
EFFORTS AND WE HAVE SOME
PROGRAMS TO WITH NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT ARE HELPING TO PUT
RESOURCES INTO ELECTRIFICATION
SECTOR. SO I WILL WRAP UP THERE
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH YOU AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO BE DOING THAT
AND THAT WAS A LOT QUICKLY BUT
THAT. YOU CAN REFER TO THOSE
SLIDES AT YOUR AT YOUR LEISURE
I APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR DOCTOR BEING HERE AND
REALLY THE THOUGHTFULNESS
BEHIND THE PRESENTATION- AND WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO THE QUEUE IN
A- APART WE WILL COME BACK TO
YOU AND POSE SOME QUESTIONS.
NEXT WE HAVE JOSE TORRES OF THE
BUILDING TO CARBONIZATION
COALITION WHO WILL DISCUSS
THEIR COALITION'S EFFORTS TO
DECARBONISE CALIFORNIA'S
BUILDINGS BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
WELCOME MR TAURUS. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHAREHOLDER JERRY
BUSS AND SOME MEMBERS- WAS IT
TOWARDS WITH THE CALIBER
CALPERS DIRECTORS WITH THE BIG
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
COALITION- JUST A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT US THE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION COALITION
UNITES BUILDING INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS. WITH ENERGY
PROVIDERS BY MENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO POWER CALPERS
HOMES AND WORK SPACES BETWEEN
ENERGY. SO THE COMMON GOAL FOR
OUR DIVERSE MEMBERSHIP. IS TO-
FOCUS ON CREATING SAFE
AFFORDABLE AND HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES THROUGH ALL ACTION
BUILDINGS- ASSETS CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR I SIX LETTERS BILLING
DEPARTMENT VEHICLE FOR CREATING
HEALTHY. AND RESILIENT HOMES
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
CENTERING EQUITY. TO PRIORITIZE
A MULTI UNIT SO SORRY NOT SURE
THE SLIDE SHOW COME ON THE OR
EXECUTIVE OUR THANK YOU WORDS
LIKE TO. THANKS SO MUCH SO YOU
KNOW WHEN WE'RE THINKING OF
BUILDING THE ORGANIZATION AND
WHAT IT MEANS TO CREATE A SAFE
HEALTHY AFFORDABLE AND
RESILIENT ALL- YEAH I THINK
MISSIONAL CAL SERVER KIND OF
PLAIN EVERYTHING OUT IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW BUILDINGS MAKE UP A
BIG CHUNK OF OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
PORTFOLIO- BUT FR THE MORE-
YOU KNOW THESE BUILDINGS ALSO
NAY MORE KNOCKS OUT OR PUT. IN
OUR CARS AND POWER PLANTS
COMBINED WHICH HAVE SEVERE
IMPACTS ON HUMAN HEALTH- SO
UNFORTUNATE LIKE MANY OTHER
THINGS RIGHT THIS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- AND IT'S
IN PART DUE OF COURSE TO-
RACISM IT'S ORG ONE JUSTICE BUT
ALSO BECAUSE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES ARE MORE
LIKELY TO LIVE IN OLDER SMALLER
THAT'S BEEN LAID MORE CROWDED
HOMES. USE GAS COOKING
EQUIPMENT FOR SPACE AND SO AS
WE THINK ABOUT REMOVING THE BUT
AND YOU KNOW COMBATING CRIME
CHANGE BECAUSE IT'S A COMMUNITY
CAN BE IN ONLINE THINK UP
BUILDING ACTED LEAD TO THE
KITCHEN OF THE KEEP SCHOOLS
GOING AT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS RIGHT HAVE
HEALTHIER MORE FOR BOTH STATE-
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE AND THEN IT
IF WE TAKE A STEP BACK AND LOOK
AT ALL THE CHALLENGED
CALIFORNIANS ARE DEALING WITH
RIGHT AND I DON'T HAVE TO
SHOULD. TELL YOU THIS RIGHT BUT
JUST FOR THE SAKE OF.
HIGHLIGHTINGWHY- YOU KNOW
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION IS A
CRITICAL PIECE- L. THE FOLKS
ALREADY HIGHLIGHTED THAT THAT
DIRE SITUATION WHEN IT COMES TO
WILDFIRES RIGHT BUT WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT HARD TO PRODUCE A
LOT OF PROJECTS. TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER BUT ONE THING WHERE WE
THINK BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION-
AND SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY HEAT
PUMPS FOR SPACE HEATING. IS WE
CAN ENSURE THAT FOLKS GET
WEATHER RIGHTS. LEAD VISION
POLLUTION FREE HOME RIGHT. IF
YOU INSTALL HEAT PUMP WITH
ILLUSTRATION. THEN THAT'S ONE
WAY TO ENSURE THAT FOLKS
PROTECTED FROM OUTDOOR
POLLUTION. AND ARE PROTECTED
INDOORS WITH THAT LEADALL-
EXTREME HEAT- YOU KNOW I KNOW A
LOT OF WORK HAS BEEN DONE- BUT
A LOT OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. CHAIRED BY SOME
EXTREME HEAT SO THAT IS THAT WE
KNOW THE RECOGNITION OF THE
HORRIBLE THINGS THAT HAPPENED
IN THE CITY OF NORTHWEST- IN
TERMS OF DEBTS AND THE NEED FOR
A LOT OF COMMUNITIES TO. OP YOU
KNOW. BE ABLE TO COMBAT AGAINST
EXTREME HEAT AND AGAIN RIGHT IN
THE PATH WICKS BUILDING
LOCATION WE CAN KEEP UP SPACE
HEATING. CAN NOT ONLY HELP US
GET CLOSE TO OUR APARTMENT.
GOALS BUT ALSO ENSURE THAT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT MOST.
IN TAKE ON YOU KNOW. REALLY BAD
SMOG TAKE ON EXTREME HEAT. AND
PROVIDE THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO
BE ABLE T FIGHTAGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL TIME AND
ALSO PREVENTS IT. GETTING WORSE
I'M EXCITED I JUST THE POINT
RUN EXTREME WHAT RIGHT PROPER
FROM INDICATOR THAT I ON
WHETHER HAVE RIGHT SO WHEN I
THINK THE COOLING RIGHT COME
FROM A DJ COMMITTEE SELF I
THINK THE FARMWORKERS
INSTRUCTOR WORKERS OR ANYONE
FOR THAT MATTER RIGHT AND I
THINK THAT WHEN THEY GET HOME
RIGHT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
HAVE RELEASED ABOUT THAT.
BACKGROUND TO PROTECT THEM FROM
THE SMOKE OUTSIDE AND SOMETHING
AND FROM THE EXTREME HEAT AND
STUFF THAT DOESN'T EXACERBATE
EVERYTHING THAT IS MAKING OUR
LIVING CONDITIONS MORE
DIFFICULT. CLIMATE CHANGE-
EXCITEMENT SO IN A ROAD MAP
RIGHT AS WE DISCUSS HOW TO GET
TO TWENTY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE BUT AS WE'VE SEEN RIGHT SB
THIRTY TO DEMONSTRATE THAT EVEN
FOR A NEW MOVIE. UP YOU KNOW
OUR NEW STATE TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE CARBON NEUTRALITY GOALS
ELECTRIFICATION IS THE ONLY
PATH TO GET THERE- AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WILL BE
ELECTRIFYING AT HOME IS THE BIG
CHALLENGE RIGHT RECOGNIZE
WORKING HARD TO DO THAT BUT WE
ALSO WANT HIGH THINK THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALREADY HAVE TAKEN
STEPS TOWARDS AN ELECTRIC
FUTURE RIGHT THROUGH NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND ABOUT FORTY
MORE. ARE CONSIDERING THIS. IT
ARE CONSIDERED AN EXISTING
BUILDINGS. SO THIS PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
PICK UP THE MANTLE AND PROVIDE
ACTED OUT OF THE FUNDING SO
THOSE COMMUNITIES. WHO NEED IT
MOST AND THE PROGRAMMING IN
EXISTING BUILDINGS CAN ALSO
REAP THE BENEFITS A BILL
ELECTRIFICATION. SO YOU KNOW
IT'S BEGIN TO ACHIEVE AS WE
THINK WE NEED A BIG INVESTMENT-
AND SO FAR. THE STATE HAS MADE
SOME INVESTMENTS AND BE AND
ALTHOUGH TO BE COMMUNITIES VERY
THANKFUL. YOU THINK THERE'S
MUCH MORE FUNDING NEEDED- YOU
KNOW THAT WHEN. 90% OF
TECHNOLOGIES COMMERCIALLY
AVAILABLE WE FEEL LIKE IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT- TO THE STATE
TO LEVERAGE THE OPPORTUNITIES
BE PROCESS PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
RELIEF TO LOCAL DISPENSED
COMMUNITIES. BY INVESTING IN
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS SO IF YOU
OPEN BUDGET FUNDING WE THINK
THEY'RE GONNA NEED AND OCT
TWENTY NOT THAT HE PLANS TO THE
SOLUTION- IT'S ALSO ONE AGAIN
ELEVATE. THE MEMORY MUST KEEP
IN AND SET HOUSE UP EFFORTS
AROUND HUBS IN OTHER OTHER
STRATEGIES AS PART OF THE
EXTREME HEAT. SOLUTION BUT WANT
TO ADD YOU KNOW. HE COMES IN
BILLION DECARBONISATION. TO THE
MIX AT NC CLARIFY RIGHT- AS WE
THINK OF THE ROAD MAP AND
GETTING TO TWENTY FORTY FIVE WE
UNDERSTAND THESE DIFFERENT
APPROACHES RIGHT THAT ARE ALL
ABOUT ELECTRIFICATION WHETHER
IT'S- TRILLION APPROACHING A
WHOLE COMMUNITY THROUGH
INVESTMENTS. AND INVESTING IN
HEAT PUMPS RIGHT BUT WE THINK
THE MOST IMMEDIATE THING WE CAN
DO WHILE PROVIDING MULTIPLE
BENEFITS AT THIS POINT IS.
INVESTING IN PEOPLE SPACEY AND
LASTLY BUT NOT. YOU KNOW. NOT
GOOD BUT VERY IMPORTANTLY
CALIFORNIA MUST COMMIT RIGHT TO
EACH IN ORACLE COMMUNITIES AND
WORKERS THAT. IT WILL LISTEN
AND CENTER EQUITY BEAMS OF ITS
WORK. AND CHECKING SOLUTIONS
THAT DO NOT COST MORE BUT
INSTEAD PROVIDE BENEFIT. AND WE
THINK THROUGH CONSISTENT
INVESTMENT WE CAN PROVIDE
MARKET CERTAINTY. TO OUR
MANUFACTURING BUT ALSO CREATE A
PLAN. THAT INSURERS YOU KNOW
WORKERS. EAT COMMUNITIES AND
EVERYONE HAS A CLEAR IDEA OF
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE-
AND- ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY. FOR YOUR TIME ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK YOU
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
NOW UP WE HAVE SERENITY COMO OF
THE HOUSING WHOSE ON EFFORTS TO
THE CAR X. MULTI FAMILY AND
AFFORDABLE RENTAL UNITS WELCOME
IS KUMAR IN HERE A GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SHANNON
DECEMBER QUEMADA AND THE
SUSTAINABLE HOUSING POLICY AND
PROGRAM MANAGER AT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
I'M GRATEFUL TO THE ASSEMBLY
UTILITY AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
FOR GIVING ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP USE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION AS A KEY FOB
FORWARD TO MEET THE STATE'S AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESERVE THE EXISTING MULTI
FAMILY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STOCK. LOW INCOME RENTERS WERE
PREDOMINANTLY BLACK AND BROWN
BATTLEGROUND OF CHINA CHANGE
IMPACTS THE FEWEST RESOURCES TO
COPE WITH ITS IMPACTS.
NONPROFIT HOUSING PROVIDERS
WILL LARGELY SO THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE PRETTY MAKING
AN EFFORT. TO ELECTRIFY THE
EXISTING BUILDING STOCK. VIDAK
AND I SEVERAL CONVENING IS HELD
INTERVIEWS WITH NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DATABASE AND
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
THEIR SAME. PRODUCT OF CATION
IT'S JUST A LACK OF STABLE
CONSISTENT AND FLEXIBLE
FUNDING. THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
FUNDING TO ELECTRIFY EXISTING
BUILDING STOCK AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO MAKE AN
ELECTRIFICATION READY. BY THE
LAUGHTER THAT I NEED THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH FUNDING FOR. PANEL
UPGRADES AND JOHNSON KNOCKED
BATES WHO GENERALLY CRESCENTA
MAKES THAT ARE INSTALLED SOME
OF THESE. EARLY OF EXPENSIVE
EQUIPMENT SUCH CLOSE. AND A LOT
OF PROGRAMS DON'T COVER THEM
BECAUSE THEY ARE PROGRAM
METRICS UP TIED TO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS AND
THESE ARE JUST AND DRUG AND
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES THAT
UNDER THE TIE BACK. TO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS YEAH INSPECTOR THAT
BECOME THAT WHEN WE IS ON HOW
FIND HOUSING IS PROBABLY SEVEN
OF YOU KNOW AS EXTREME CALM AND
EXPENSIVE PROVIDERS TO MAKE
THAT OF OCCUPATIONS THEY NEED
TO SHOW MASSIVE COST PER UNIT
AND A TO BRING EXISTING
BUILDINGS OUT TO SOME OF THOSE
THAT WILL. ALSO BE FINDING THAT
HOUSING PROGRAMS SOMETIMES
ACTUALLY PENALIZE PROVIDERS OR.
PROVIDING ELECTRICITY INTO
HOMES LIVING ON SOME OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE ALSO IN THE
WORLD AND THERE'S A NEED FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SUPPORT
NOT JUST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROVIDERS BUT ALSO THE INDUSTRY
THAT SEPTEMBER CHANGED ITS
CONTRACTORS. ARCHITECTS AND
ENGINEERS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
RESIDENTS BOTH RECEIVE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY BENEFITS BUT
ALSO NOT BETTING ON DEEP AND
BACKS. THE DATA AND DATA PLUS
THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK INTO
THE FOLLOWING RECOMMENDATION.
ONE IS JUST PROVIDING LOS TAPER
AND CONSISTENT FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROVIDE
ECSTATIC TO FIND AN EXISTING
BUILDING STOCK. AND TO FUND.
UPGRADES LIKE KIND OF GRAYSON
TRANSFORM UPGRADES WHICH GO
BEYOND GHG EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
METRICS ONE SUCH PROGRAMS THAT
ARE INCOMPATIBLE DAY STATION
PROGRAM WHICH CURRENTLY HAS A
WEAKNESS TO EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS ONE ALL LOWER INCOME
ALL LIVING IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SECOND IS ENSURING
THAT HOUSING PROGRAMS CONSIDER
THE LONG TERM HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC. IMPACTS OF CAPITAL
GAS APPLIANCES INTERESTED IN
SCHOOL ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS HOMES AND
REALLY ALLOWING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROVIDERS TO MAKE
ELECTRIFICATION OF UPGRADES BY
TREATING IT AS A PUBLIC BENEFIT
SO IT IS JUST ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE ELECTRIFICATION FRIENDLY
THREE. AND THE LAST IS
PROVIDING ROBUST TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE IN
CONCLUSION I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT HEALTHY RECIPE AND ARMS
CANNOT BE A LUXURY ATTACKS IT'S
NOT FOR THE CONTACT WE HAVE
KNOCKED WITH. THE ECONOMIC
BURDENS AND ENERGY BURDENS AND
THE USUALLY DANCE BURDENS FACED
BY LOWER INCOME CALIFORNIANS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
PRIORITISED AS A MEANS TO
EQUITABLY ELECTRIFYING OF
BUILDINGS AND BELIEVE THAT AN
EQUITABLE ALLOCATION POLICY.
COULD I ADDRESS SOME OF THIS
ARTICLE AND MY MENTAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICES RATHER THAN
JUST AS THIS OP THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOU ON THIS
ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY AND
HOUSING AND HOW MULTI FAMILY
HOMES- CAN BE TRANSITION
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS ONE OF
OUR- MAJOR CHALLENGES GOING
FORWARD THE NEXT WE HAVE JOSH
GREEN OF A. O. SMITH
CORPORATION WHO WILL DISCUSS
TECHNOLOGICAL CHALLENGES OF
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
DECARBONISATION WELCOME MR
GREEN. AFTERNOON- CHAIR HOLDING
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN OKAY
VERY GOOD- THANK YOU AND- I'M
GONNA JUMP INTO A COUPLE OF
SLIDES IN MY TESTIMONY BUT-
JUST AS A CURSORY MARC LIKE TO
THANK. YOU CHAIR HOLDEN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- TERRY OF US-
FOR AFFORDING A- SMITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
AND ON BEHALF OF THE COMPANY IN
OUR FIFTEEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
AROUND THE WORLD AGAIN WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU- OR- OUR
PARTICIPATION HERE- AS A
FOUNDATIONAL MATTER- AO SMITH-
WHICH IS BEEN INNOVATING- SINCE
ITS FOUNDING. IN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR IN MILWAUKEE
WISCONSIN I'M HERE WE'RE THE
LARGEST MANUFACTURER OF
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL
WATER HEATING HYDRONIC HEATING
BOILERS- AND POOL HEATERS- WE
RECOGNIZE THAT AND APPRECIATE
THAT REDUCING THE CARBON
INTENSITY OF BUILDINGS- AND IS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT AS PART OF
BROADER POLICY INITIATIVES TO
DECARBONIZE OUR ECONOMY. TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ALONG THOSE LINES WE'VE
BUILT AN ANALYTICAL TOOL THAT
CAN ASSIST POLICY MAKERS AS
WELL AS OUR CUSTOMERS. AND
UNDERSTANDING WATER HEATING
SOLUTION SCENARIOS- BASED ON
STATE LOCAL ENERGY DATA AS WELL
AS SITE CONDITIONS- WHEN
CONTEMPLATING OR NAVIGATING
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
POLICIES- AND OTHER RELATED TO
CIVICALLY TO EXISTING
BUILDINGS. ANY TRANSITION AWAY
FROM UTILIZING NATURAL GAS FOR
SPACE AND WATER HEATING TO
ELECTRICITY EXCLUSIVELY I THINK
AS WE'VE HEARD A PRESENTS
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES- FOR
BOTH THE PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE- THE ELECTRICITY
GRID MODERNIZATION ISSUES THAT
COME ALONG WITH THAT AND QUITE
BY CANDIDLY A CONSUMER
AWARENESS AND ACCEPTANCE. I'M
SO AS IT RELATES SPECIFICALLY-
TO IF YOU CAN- CC BY MY CAN YOU
SEE MY SLOW SHARE THE WELL-
THEY'RE KIND OF MOVING ON THE
SIDE THERE THERE ON THE SCREEN
BUT THEY'RE NOT OKAY. ALL RIGHT
THERE'S I WANT TO MOVE TO JUST
THE THREE SLIDES AROUND UP BUT
THIS AND OPRY'S AND TATIAN
MODE- SO WE CAN HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING SKEWS ME SO AS
OUR AS OUR HEAT PUMP WATER
HEATERS AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE CHIEF
TECHNOLOGIES- THAT WILL HELP
ADDRESS BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION. L. A. O. SMITH
HAS TECHNOLOGIES TO ADDRESS
MANY OF THE BUILDING STOCK
CHALLENGES MULTI FAMILY YOU CAN
SEE HERE COMMERCIAL LIKE
COMMERCIAL KITCHENS RESTAURANTS
AND OF COURSE A RESIDENTIAL- SO
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IN TERMS
OF OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE THERE
IS A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY- WE
TALK ABOUT NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
ENSURE HOLDEN YOU ADDRESS THIS
IS AS WELL AS OTHERS. I'D
ALWAYS THE EASIEST TIME TO
INSTALL- KEEP UP WATER HEATERS
AND MORE INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES- ENTITLED TWENTY
FOUR AND CALIFORNIANS- CODE- IS
GOING TO HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVES FOR BUILDERS- TO
INSTALL HEAT PUMP WATER HEATERS
THAT'S GREAT- REBATE PROGRAMS
ARE FRIENDS AND UTILITY
COMMUNITY- ARE VERY ADROIT AT
AT IMPLEMENTING ARE ALSO A KEY
PIECE- GETTING CONSUMER
AWARENESS UP- IS THIS AN
OPPORTUNITY CONTRACTOR
TRAINING. AND WE ALLUDED TO
THIS- AND I THINK ONE OF MY
FELLOW PANELISTS TALKED ABOUT
THIS IN THE MULTI FAMILY
CONTEXT I'M THE RETROFITTING
REPLACEMENT CENTER PROGRAMS ARE
CURRENTLY IN PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA- THE ACRONYMS OF
TACK AND BUILD IN AN ESCAPE-
OVER A QUARTER OF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING- CERTAINLY
OVER THE NEXT. TWO. CONTINUE ON
THE TRACK- AS RELATES TO- THE
EXISTING STOCK THESE ARE JUST
SOME OTHER OPPORTUNITIES THE
SLIDES AND I KNOW OUR SLIDES
ARE WERE MADE PART OF THE
RECORD TO WORK WELL ON THIS- A
TO MUCH BUT THIS IS JUST A
SNAPSHOT IN REAL TIME- LAYERED
ON TOP OF TITLE TWENTY FOUR
HOURS. CODE REQUIREMENTS FOR
BOTH SINGLE FAMILY AND MULTI
FAMILY WARY OF SMITH ON A SEIZE
UP BOTH NEW CONSTRUCTION AS
WELL AS RETROFIT REPLACEMENT
ACTIVITY- CERTAINLY OVER THE
NEXT- TWO YEARS FINALLY
CHALLENGES AND I KNOW THAT'S A
KEY PART OF OUR- OF THE HEARING
TODAY- SO WE TALK ABOUT A LOT
OF THE BUILDING STOCK IS OLDER-
THERE ARE SPACE CONSTRAINTS AS
RESPECTS RELATES TO HEAT PUMP
WATER HEATING EQUIPMENT. UP WE
HAVE INCENTIVES BETWEEN THE
BUILDING. BUILDING OWNERS-
CERTAINLY RENTERS- AND WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THAT CAPITAL
EXPENDITURES FOR OUR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ESPECIALLY IN
THE RESTAURANT. AND LODGING AND
HOSPITALITY COMMUNITY. AN END
HEAT PUMP WATER HEATERS WHILE
ARE VERY INNOVATIVE AND
CERTAINLY THE MOST EFFICIENT
WAY TO KEEP WATER. THEY'RE
STILL IN TECHNOLOGY. AND JUST
TO GIVE THE COMMITTEE A SCALE.
EIGHT MILLION WATER HEATERS
THAT ARE SOLD ANNUALLY IN THE
UNITED STATES. RIGHT NOW A
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THOSE ARE
HEAT PUMP WATER HEATERS. IN
CALIFORNIA ABOUT TEN MILLION
WATER HEATERS IN THE INSTALL
BASE 90% OF THOSE ARE GAS
FIRED. SO WE'RE LOOKING AT NINE
BILLION WATER HEATERS TO
CONVERT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. EIGHT MILLION WATER
HEATERS BEING MANUFACTURED
ANNUALLY YOU CAN SEE THERE'S A
DELTA THERE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. BUT ALSO AS
COMMISSIONER MCALLISTER A
REFERENCE ACOSTA. RIGHT THAT'S
SOMEWHAT SIGNIFICANT- AND
CERTAINLY WE WOULD REFER TO
POLICY MAKERS ON THE ECONOMICS
OF THE POLITICAL FEASIBILITY OF
LONG LASTING FUNDING IN THAT
REGARD. BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
GOING TO BE NEEDED I CERTAINLY
HAS A MANUFACTURER- AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OUR
INDUSTRY YEAH WE'RE LOOKING AT
OTHER SUPPLY CHAIN MATERIAL
ISSUES- GRANTED WE'RE IN THIS
KIND OF. CODED YOU KNOW POST
CODE EIGHT. A SITUATION- BUT
THOSE ARE ALSO CHALLENGES THAT
THAT WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS. SO
IN CONCLUSION WANTED TO BE
EFFICIENT WITH OUR TESTIMONY-
CERTAINLY REDUCING CARBON
INTENSITY BUILDINGS PART OF A
BROADER DE CAR POLICIES. THE
QUICK TRANSITION AWAY IS GOING
TO HAVE SOME CHALLENGES BUT
AGAIN THEY. CAN BE OVERCOME WE
DO HAVE TO LOOK AT THE X. X. A
RETROFIT MILLION OF HOUSE AND
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS- BUT A. O.
SMITH STANDS READY TO BE A
RESOURCE AND A PARTNER AND I
JUST WANT TO STRESS THAT- WE'VE
HAD WONDERFUL WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS CERTAINLY IN THE
ASSEMBLY- MANY THE VARIOUS
COMMISSIONS WITH COMMISSIONER
MCALLISTER AND HIS STAFF. AND
WE'RE HERE TO BE A RESOURCE-
AND ONCE AGAIN WANT TO THANK
YOU- CHAIR HOLDEN. AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY THANK YOU MISTER GREEN
APPRECIATION PRESENTATION. NEXT
WE HAVE YURI FRIEDMAN OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS WHO
WILL DISCUSS POTENTIAL
DECARBONIZATION STRATEGIES
APART FROM ELECTRIFICATION.
WELCOME MR FRIEDMAN.
SHAREHOLDERS WITH THAT CHERRY
EVANS COMMISSIONER MCALLISTER
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT. I'M GOING INTO A
PROJECT MY SLIDES OR AT THE
VERY LEAST HELPFUL MY ABSOLUTE
BEST TO TRY THAT AND. BUT I
CAN'T HELP YOU CAN HELP ME
BECAUSE I HAVE A LITTLE
STRUGGLING TRYING TO PULL
SLIDES UP I WAS WONDERING
WHETHER WE SHOP WITH THE SLIDES.
WHILE WORKING ON THAT WILL TRY
TO ASSIST YOU THIS RESTORING
EVERYONE SECOND I'M HOPING THAT
WE ARE SIX BEST PHONE FORTUNE
WHEN I CUT COULD NOT SEIZE THE
MOMENT APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY.
WE HAVE AN IMAGE ON OUR SCREEN
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S WHERE
YOU WANT KNOW WHAT I'D LIKE IT
IS VOTE FOR ONE OF THAT-
SUPPORTING MEMBERS AS WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER THE PROJECT
MY SLIDE BUT UNFORTUNATELY YEAR
ONE SECOND WITHOUT HAVING
DIFFICULT YEAH AND WHEN THE
SOFTWARE. WELL. CAN CAN YOU
PLEASE HELP ME WITH THAT THE
PROJECT MY PRESENTATION. I
THINK THEY'RE WORKING ON IT NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE A
PATIENT THAT'S IT LET LET'S GO
THE FIRST LANGUAGE. BUT NEXT
WEAPONS. THANK YOU IT IS THERE
AND AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
WAY THESE THAT THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT SLIDE THAT FRAME THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT
DECARBONIZATION IN THE TERMS
THAT WE NEED TO DISCUSS SIMILAR
TO A COMPLEX. OUR OBJECTIVE AND
I'D LIKE TO DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION WITH THEIR RIGHT HAND
SIDE OF THIS CHART THE SERVICE
CHARGES THE SUMMER ANALYSIS
THAT ASKS THE QUESTION. WHAT T
WILL TAKE FOR US. ON A GLOBAL
SCALE. TO REACH THE GOAL OF
LIMITING GLOBAL WARMING HAVE
DEGREES AND THE CONCLUSION THAT
THEN ELSE'S CONDUCTED BY
BLOOMBERG NEW ENERGY FINANCE.
REACHED WAS THAT AS YOU CAN SEE
ON THE RIGHT HAND SIDE THE
CONTRIBUTION OF BALLOT TRUMP'S
OF MOLECULES. TO THE ENERGY
MAKES IS ABOUT EQUAL BETTER
BELIEVE IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
KEEP THEM ALL BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS SPENT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF EFFORT BEEN ACCOMPLISHED A
LOT. IN ADVANCE OF A GENDER
OFTEN ALCOHOLS I BELIEVE THE
FOR US TO BE SUCCESSFUL
DEVELOPMENT SOLUTIONS THAT NOT
ONLY LAW CALIFORNIANS REGION'S
GOALS BUT THE ULTIMATE
ULTIMATELY SERVE AS THE EXAMPLE
OF THE MODEL AS A TEMPLATE FOR
THE WORLD. WE NEED TO ADVANCE
OUR ADOPTION OF THE MOLECULES
AS VIGOROUSLY AS WE HAVE
ADVANCED. PROBLEMS OF THESE
SMALLER THIS IS FAIRLY BROAD
SET OF THIS YEAR EMISSION AND
THANK WILL NATURAL GAS FIVE.
AND HYDROGEN THE BED BLACKBOOK
THE BOTTLE OF WATER BOND IN
SPECIFICALLY HYDROGEN. EXACTLY
IS BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT I THINK- YEAH WE CAN TAKE
AWAY ASHRAMS BETH ALSO GREEN
HYDROGEN UP OYSTER RAP OF THE
CHART IN FRONT OF YOU IS NOT A
FORECAST IT'S VERY ALLOCATE
WHAT HAPPENS WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THE RENEWABLE POWER PRICES IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST
DECADE. IT'S REMARKABLE THAT
THEY DECLINE A FULL ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE IN THE SPACE OF ABOUT
DECADES. AND THAT IS THE SINGLE
BIGGEST COMPONENT OF PASTA
GREAT PACKAGE WAS AGREED
HYDROGEN IS. IS TAKEN WATER AND
USING POWER INCREASINGLY
RENEWABLE POWER TO PRODUCE
HYDROGEN SO AS RENEWABLE POWER
PRICES DECLINE. SO DOES THE
COST OF REPACKAGING MAKE IT
AFFORDABLE FUEL. THANKS BYE
WHICH IMPORTANT ELEMENT IN THIS
LIGHT IS THAT- GREEN HYDROGEN
CAN BE USED FOR YOU CAPITALIZE
MULTIPLE SECTORS. AND AGAIN I
WOULD DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE RIGHT HAND SIDE OF THE
SLIDE YOU SEE ALL THE SECTORS
BUT PRIVATE TREATMENT BE
APPLICABLE IT IS THE PARALYZING
TRANSPORTATION. ESPECIALLY
HEAVY DUTY TRANSPORTATION WHERE
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE
THAT SOLUTION OF CHOICE. IT CAN
ALSO BE USED AND THEY ARE WHY
OUR WEEKS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THIS CONVERSATION IT CAN BE
USED FOR ANY PURPOSE BUILDINGS
AND I'LL SHARE WITH YOU LATER
ON SOME OF THE WORK ON. THEIR
WEIGHT. AND IN OUR STATE NEXT I
PLEASE. AS I TRIED TO SUMMARIZE
IN THIS LIVE AT LEAST FOLLOW
THE FACTS ABOUT WHAT'S BEING
DONE WORLDWIDE EXPLORE USING
HYDROGEN FOR FUEL THE
DECARBONISATION IN THE U. K.
THERE IS A OR ON THEIR WAY TO.
EXAMINE CONVERSION OF CALLS HE
TOOK LEAVES WHICH MEANS BY FROM
METRICS THE THOUSANDS LARGEST
CITY IN THE U. K. THE 100%
PACKAGE ANOTHER HAVE PROFOUND
WAY IS WHAT THEY CALL HIGH FOR.
WHICH IS ALSO EXAMINING EVERY
PLACEMENTOF MATH AND WITH
HYDROGEN THERE IS A VAST OPEN
MARSHALL BUILDINGS OUR
NEIGHBORS TO THE NORTH HAPPENED
CAMPUS ARE ACTUALLY WORKING ON
BLANDING AND ANOTHER FIFTY
FIELD CONDITIONS WHEN THE
HYDROGEN NATURAL GAS GREAT.
ENABLE DIFFERENT REALIZATION OF
AND USE THAT'S HAPPENING IN
ONTARIO AND QUEBEC AND BRITISH
PHAM ARE CLOSE BEHIND STUDY
THAT'S- ANOTHER IMPORTANT
ELEMENT OF WHAT FIVE G. AND THE
BUILDINGS. IS THEIR FUEL CELLS
WHICH RAMAN HIDING. BUT THEY
DESCRIBED HIM AS MAY THE FACT
IRWIN SIDE WHO WILL SELL THESE
AND NATURAL GAS BUT RIGHT NOW
MAJOR MANUFACTURERS SUCH AS
FUNDS FUNNY. ARE ALL IN ALL OF
THE PRODUCTS THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH. ON YOUR HYDROGEN FUEL
CELLS IN OUR STATE FLAG THE OUR
OWN BILL FOR ENERGY RECENT DR
THE PHONE BILLS ON HIGHBRIDGE
WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN X. OF USING
HYDROGEN BUILDINGS. IT'S BEEN
BLENDED INTO THAT NATURAL GAS
NETWORK AT ON THE CAMPUS OF
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE
AND WE AT CIRCLE GAS OUR
BUILDING RIGHT NOW
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT WHICH IS
GOING TO DEMONSTRATE THE
POTENTIAL HYDROGEN LAST
BUILDINGS OR H. TWO HYDROGEN
ALL LET'S GO TO NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE SO THEY CAN TAKE AWAY AS
I'D LIKE TO LEAVE YOU WITH IS
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THE
COMBINATION APPROACH NEEDS TO
BE HOLISTIC AND WHAT THAT MEANS
IS THAT BASICALLY WAS A
TREMENDOUS FOR ALL FOUR THREE
SCHEME TO PROVIDE YOU BUILDINGS
WE BELIEVE THERE'S A ROLE FOR
US TRONG AND FROM ALL ANGLES
IN. APPRECIATION FOR EXISTING
BUILDING STOCK WE BELIEVE THIS
POLICYMAKERS SUPPOSED TO CAN
EVEN PLAY ADVANCED JAVA AND ONE
GOAL TO USE THAT WOULD BE ARE
YOU WILL GUESS THAT. WOULD
INCORPORATE MULTIPLE CLEAN
GUEST BATH WAYS AND THE LAST
BUT NOT THE LEAST WE BELIEVE
AND FEEL STRONGLY THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS STATEWIDE I
DIDN'T STRATEGIES. WHICH IS
GOING TO BE INTEGRATED ACROSS
THE VARIOUS SOURCES OF FIBER
JIM VERY ISSUES. AND ONE
EXAMPLE OF THAT APPROACH THAT'S
NOT BEING ACTIVELY DISCUSSED AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL AS WELL AS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IS A
CONVERSATION ABOUT INDUSTRIAL
HUBS WHICH ARE AT THE POTENTIAL.
FOR A LOT OF HYDROGEN SCALE HIM
TO MEETING CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ATTENTION THANK
YOU MISS FRIEDMAN WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION AND CLEARLY
HYDROGEN IS PART OF A
CONVERSATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO MAYBE HAVING SOME
QUESTIONS THAT'LL BRING US
BACK. INTO THAT TOPIC WITH YOU
AND OTHERS FINALLY WE HAVE
DOCTOR MICHAEL WERE A OF THE
WOODS INSTITUTE AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY WHO WILL DISCUSS THE
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES AS
THE STATE FACES THIS
DECARBONIZATION TRANSITION
WELCOME. DOCTOR WERE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU'RE HOLDEN AND
SHERRY THAT'S FOR INVITING ME
TO TESTIFY- BEFORE THIS HEARING
TODAY. WE RECENTLY COMPLETED
ANALYSIS- FOCUSED ON THE COSTS
OF DIFFERENT PATHWAYS. TO
DECARBONISATION OF RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS AND MORE GENERALLY
THE GASTRO FUSION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M GONNA SHARE
SOME INCLUSIONS FROM NETWORK
AND MAYBE EXTEND A LITTLE BIT-
UPON THEM TODAY- OUR ANALYSIS
TARGETED- YOU KNOW QUESTIONS
AROUND WHAT RATED PACKS
DIFFERENT PATHWAYS TO. NATURAL
GAS SYSTEM DECARBONISATION-
MIGHT HAPPEN SO WE EVALUATED
FOUR SCENARIOS- THE FIRST LOOK
AT TITLE TWENTY FOUR AND
FOCUSED ON NEW BUILDINGS I
WON'T DISCUSS THAT TODAY BUT
THE REMAINING THREE FOCUSED ON
THE EXISTING BUILDING FULLY
ARMED PARTICULAR- WE TRY TO
EVALUATE THE RATE IMPACTS TO
REMAINING NATURAL GAS CUSTOMERS
SO THAT THE FOLKS THAT ARE KIND
OF LEFT BEHIND IN A GAS
TRANSITION PERHAPS. OF THREE
APPROACHES THE FIRST WAS A BAN
ON THE SALE OF EXISTING POWER
GAS APPLIANCES THE SECOND WAS-
INCREASED USE OF. RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS HYDROGEN AND-
SYNTHETIC NATURAL GAS IN THE
EXISTING PIPELINE SYSTEM
RECOGNIZING CONSTRAINTS ON THE
SUPPLIES OF ALL THREE OF THOSE-
RESOURCES AND THE THIRD WAS-
STRATEGIC DECOMMISSIONING OF
THE NATURAL GAS SYSTEMATIC
GOING INTO PARTICULAR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND USING
SUBSIDIES AND VARIOUS OTHER
APPROACHES ELECTRIFYING IN
NEIGHBORHOOD IN ORDER TO THEN
DECOMMISSIONING GAS SYSTEM THE
LAST MILE OF GAS SERVICE WITHIN
THAT NEIGHBORHOOD ONCE IT HAD
COMPLETELY ELECTRIFIED AND I'LL
JUST SUMMARIZE OUR CONCLUSIONS
QUICKLY AND THEN AND THEN GO
INTO THAT MORE DEEPLY IT THAT
THERE ARE NOW THIS IS- SUGGESTS
A COUPLE OF THINGS THE FIRST IS
THAT BECAUSE OF SAFETY
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE. ALREADY
GOING TO OCCUR GAS RATES ARE
GONNA INCREASE QUITE
SUBSTANTIALLY OVER THE NEXT
DECADE. AND THAT'S BAKED IN-
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
ALREADY GONNA HAPPEN. AND IT
NEEDS TO BE PART OF THE BASE
PLAN UNDERSTOOD TO BE. PART OF
THE BASE LINE SO. THEY'RE GOING
TO BE IMPACTS BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE SAFETY- IMPROVEMENTS
AFTER. BOTH SAN BRUNO AND LISA
CANYON. THAT ARE GONNA RAISE
COSTS AND ALREADY ARE RAISING
COSTS FOR RATEPAYERS.
INDEPENDENT OF ANY KIND OF-
COSTS VARIATION ACROSS THE
NATURAL GAS. THE SECOND MAIN
CONCLUSION AND WE ARRIVED AT
USING- WHEN I SHOULD SAY WE
UTILIZED A MODIFIED VERSION OF
THE E. THREE- NATURAL GAS RATE
MODEL THAT WAS DEVELOPED FOR
THE ENERGY COMMISSION AS PART
OF ITS WORK ON BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION EATERY WAS KIND
OF NOT SURE MODEL WITH US. AND
WE OP AND MODIFIED BOTTLE
FURTHER TO UNDERTAKE THE
NONSENSE. BUT THE OTHER MAIN
CONCLUSION THAT WE COME TO YOU.
IS THAT WHAT ALL THREE
POLICIES- BUT I JUST I
MENTIONED. HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TO SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE.
BUILDING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THEY HAVE WIDELY
VARYING COSTS IN PARTICULAR-
AND APPLIANCE FAN OR IN
APPROACH INVOLVED BIOMETHANE
JOHN GREEN HYDROGEN AND
SYNTHETIC NATURAL GAS APPEAR TO
RAISE RATES QUITE SUBSTANTIALLY
ALSO WHILE PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT EMISSION REDUCTIONS
BY CONTRAST STRATEGIC
DECOMMISSIONING OF THE GAS
SYSTEM COULD HAVE MINIMAL
EFFECTS ON RATES AND AT THE
SAME TIME PRODUCE LARGE
EMISSION REDUCTIONS SO THAT
SOUNDS LIKE AN OBVIOUS CHOICE
BUT I THINK THERE ARE IT'S
IMPORTANT RECOGNIZED A COUPLE
OF- CABBIE OUTS ONE IS THAT. WE
DON'T CONSIDER THE OTHER SIDE
EQUATION RIGHT THE COSTS OF THE
INCENTIVES THAT ARE GONNA BE
NECESSARY TO WHO TO DRIVE-
STRATEGIC DECOMMISSIONING WE
ALSO- AND WE POINT TO THIS IN
THE REPORT AND I WOULD ALSO
RECOMMEND THE WORD THE RECENT
MARKETABILITY CARBONIZATION
COALITION ON THIS ISSUE WE ALSO
DON'T CAREFULLY EXAMINE IN THIS
WORK THE COMPLEXITY OF SUCH AN
UNDERTAKING AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
COMPLICATIONS WITH HER SHE'S
STRATEGIC TO COMMISSION
RIDICULOUS OR- THERE NEEDS TO
BE THERE ARE PROBABLY NEED TO
BE- LEGAL CLARIFICATION. ON
THAT YOU TO GAS UTILITIES
OBLIGATION TO SERVE- ANY
ABILITY- UTILITY TO SUBSTITUTE
GAS OR ELECTRIC SERVICE FOR GAS
SERVICE NOT THAT GETS INTO YOU
KNOW QUESTIONS OF ENERGY LAW
AND SECTION FORTY ONE IN THE
UTILITY COAT. BUT I THINK. IT'S
LIKELY THAT IN ORDER TO CREATE
CERTAINTY FOR THE UTILITIES
THAT WOULD HAVE TO MAKE THESE
LARGE INVESTMENTS- WE NEED TO
PROVIDE SOME SORT OF.
CLARIFICATION FOR THEM THERE ON
THE LEGAL SIDE- THE OTHER THE
OTHER COMPLICATION THAT WE
IDENTIFY AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ADDRESS IS REALLY ABOUT CHOICE
AND HALFPENNY THESE ARE MAJOR
CHANGES IN THE WAIT ENERGY
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED. AND WE
POINT S. AS DO OTHERS TO THE
SUCCESS OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY PILOTS. AND IMPORTANT
EXAMPLES FOR EMPOWERING
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE CHOICES
ABOUT THEIR OWN ENERGY FUTURES
AND- WE ARGUE THAT- THERE ISN'T
THERE IN EVEN AS WE SEEK
EFFECTIVE PATHWAYS TO MOVE
FORWARD IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT
THE STATE THE PC ENERGY
COMMISSION- PARTNER WITH
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THESE CHOICES ARE TAKEN- IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE PUBLIC DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE AND- WITH SURE INCE'S
BACKS FUNDING WILL BE
FORTHCOMING TO ALLOW FOR
EQUITABLE CONVERSION IF THAT'S
THE CHOICE IT'S MADE THE LAST
THING I'D SAY CONCLUSION IS
THAT ONE IMPORTANT- ASPECT OF
OUR EXAMINATION OF RATE IMPACTS
IS THAT THEY CAN BE ADDED TO
AND SO THERE ARE REAL CONCERNS
ABOUT FOR TAKING IN ALL OF THE
ABOVE STRATEGY WHEN IT COMES TO
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
BECAUSE IF WE IF WE FOR
EXAMPLE. ARE PURSUE A TOTAL
TWENTY FOUR STRATEGY AND
PURSUE- BROWN METHANE STRATEGY
AND PURSUE AN APPLIANCE BRAND
STRATEGY IT COSTS MAY BE ADDED
AND WE MAY FIND THAT- RATE
PAYERS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
ELECTRIFY OR ENOUGH PERHAPS
BECAUSE THEY ARE TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS CHOOSE NOT TO. MY
FACE ESCALATING RATE IMPACTS
DUE TO THE SORT OF COMBINATION
STRATEGY WHICH SO OUR
CONCLUSION RECOMMENDATION IS
THAT BRANCH GROANING OR
STRATEGIC DECOMMISSIONING IS
REALLY THE BEST STRATEGY AT
THIS THIS POINT IN TIME TO
EXAMINE. AND THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN THE GAS SYSTEM TO AVOID
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE UPCOMING.
BYE BYE- SELECTING AREAS WHERE
WORST WE'RE DECOMMISSIONING
COULD OCCUR AND ASSISTING
HOMEOWNERS AND COMMERCIAL
ENTITIES TO MAKE THE TRANSITION
AS AS NECESSARY. WE CAN ALSO BY
DOING THAT. TYLER APPROACH
REALLY LEARN ABOUT WHAT THE
BEST APPROACH IS ARE. I JUST
INCLUDES- BY SAYING THAT WE'VE
DONE THIS BEFORE IN CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE NUMEROUS EXAMPLES
FROM HISTORY MOST NOTABLY THE
TRANSITION FOR MANUFACTURE GAS
AND NATURAL GAS WORK MAJOR
INTERVENTIONS BY UTILITIES WERE
MADE- TO SORT OF SWITCH THE WAY
THAT ENERGY SERVICES WERE BEING
PROVIDED TO. OUR RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS. THERE
ARE PRECEDENTS. THERE ARE
CHALLENGING THEY REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT EFFORT IN
COORDINATION BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS UTILITIES THAT
SERVE CUSTOMERS AND THE STATE
AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THAT CAN
OCCUR. AND THEN WE CAN SEE A
FUTURE WHERE OUR BUILDINGS- ARE
DOING THEIR PART TO HELP US
ACHIEVE OUR TWENTY THIRTY AND
TWENTY FORTY FIVE CLIENT
TARGETS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU DR LAURA AND I'D LIKE
TO THANK ALL OF OUR PANELISTS
FOR THEIR REALLY COMPREHENSIVE
OVERVIEW. AND FOR HIGHLIGHTING
THE WAYS THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
MANY OF THESE CHALLENGES. MUCH
OF THE FOCUS TODAY HAS BEEN ON
BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION AS A
SOLUTION. TO DECARBONISATION
EFFORTS SO QUESTION THAT I LIKE
TO THE MOVIES GET A STAR ON
THIS- WOULD BE AND TO WHOEVER
FEELS UNCOMFORTABLE JUMPING IN
ANSWER TO. A SHOULD
ELECTRIFICATION REMAIN A
CENTRAL FOCUS IF WE'RE
DISCUSSING EXISTING BUILDINGS
HOW MIGHT OTHER SOLUTIONS LIKE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY RETROFITS AND
RENEWABLE GAS OR DOCTOR
FRIEDMAN BROUGHT UP HYDROGEN BE
IMPLEMENTED ALONGSIDE
ELECTRIFICATION TO PROMOTE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION WITH
THESE BE GOOD CONCURRENT
INVESTMENTS WHY OR WHY NOT. AND
THAT'S FOR WHOEVER'S JEREMY BUT
I'M I'M WONDERING OUR JUST
SORRY IN TERMS OF THE- JUST THE
INTERACTION HERE SHALL WE ALL
MAYBE PUT OUR CAMERAS ON SO WE
CAN ALL KIND OF RESPOND PERHAPS
ANYWAY WHO ARE SO I THINK I
WANT TO KEEP SOMETHING THAT
DOCTOR OR A SAD- WHICH IS THAT
TIGHT COORDINATION IS REQUIRED-
GEOGRAPHICALLY AND BY SECTOR
WORKING WITH SPECIFIC PEOPLE
THERE ON SPECIFIC YOU KNOW
BUILDINGS LOADS THAT ARE ON- IN
ONE GEOGRAPHICAL AREA SO WE CAN
STRATEGICALLY- INVEST IN
ELECTRIC SYSTEM- PRUNING COULD
GAS SYSTEM THAT'S THE STRATEGY-
AND THAT. DOING SO WILL
POTENTIALLY ENABLE- ARE IN G.
TO THE EXTENT THAT IT'S
AVAILABLE AT SOME VOLUME TO
FOCUS ON THE HARDEST TO
ELECTRIFY SECTORS OUR OUR
BUILDING THE CONVERSATION
ASSESSMENT FOUND THAT THAT WAS
AFFIXED A RELATIVELY EXPENSIVE
STRATEGY- AND THAT THE VOLUME
OF IT WAS NOT AS WE CURRENTLY
UNDERSTAND THAT ENOUGH TO GET
US THE BUGS THAT THAT
THRESHOLD- BUT- THE HIGH VALUES
THERMAL APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
HARD TO ELECTRIFY ACROSS THE
STATE PARTICULAR INDUSTRY- AND
SOME OTHER- IN USES ARE. PLACES
WHERE YOU KNOW WITHOUT
GEOGRAPHICAL CORRECT YOU COULD-
POTENTIALLY FOCUS THOSE QUEEN
MOLECULES WHERE THEY ARE
RUNNING THE MOST VALUE- SO
AGAIN I CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH
THAT THAT COMMUNITY BASED
FIRST- AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
IN TIGHT GEOGRAPHICAL
COORDINATION ACROSS THE STATE
WITH THE RELEVANT UTILITIES
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IS REALLY
KEY. FOR DOING THIS. IN AN
OPTIMIZED WHAT THANK YOU
PERSICA I LOOKED TO MY TO SEE
IF ANYONE ELSE DR COURT. THIS
IS THE CHAIR'S SEAT AND HE'S
OBVIOUSLY A LOT TALLER THAN I
HAVE. SO COMMISSION MCALLISTER
YOU'RE THE PERSON I'D LIKE TO
BRING THESE UP TO- FIRST OF ALL
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT NATURAL GAS.
THE DIFFICULTY WITH EVEN WITH
PHASING OUT PERHAPS A
PARTICULAR REGION IS THAT
THERE'S A HUGE INFRASTRUCTURE
BRINGING NATURAL GAS INTO THE
STATE- IT CETERA THE COST OF
NATURAL GAS FOR THE REMAINING
CUSTOMERS IS JUST GOING TO
EXPLODE AND SUPPOSE YOU WERE TO
GET RID OF YOU KNOW HALF THE
NATURAL GAS SYSTEM THE OTHER
HALF WOULD JUST HAVE USED COSTS
SO I THINK THERE'S A REAL
CONCERN THAT HAS TO BE STUDIED
DEEPLY TO UNDERSTAND THIS NOW I
ALSO AGREE WITH YOU THAT
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS IS NOT
GOING TO BE ENOUGH OF IT TO DO
MORE THAN YOU KNOW REDUCE
PERHAPS OVERALL- MIND- METHANE
SOMEWHAT BUT NOT A WHOLE LOT- I
DO THINK HYDROGEN IS A
POTENTIAL ANSWER AND CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW I WAS IN NEW ENGLAND
WHEN THEY MADE THE TRANSITION
FROM COAL GAS TO- NATURAL GAS
AND THAT WAS EASY YOU KNOW THEY
JUST A FEW VALVES WERE SWITCHED
ON- THE HEATING SYSTEMS-
COOKING SYSTEM AT CETERA WE
DON'T KNOW WITH HYDROGEN WHAT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE. WHETHER OR
NOT WILL BE ABLE TO USE CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE JUST MANY
QUESTIONS. THAT NEED TO BE
ANSWERED SO BEFORE WE START
DOWN THAT PATH WE REALLY NEED
TO DO A WHOLE LOT OF WORK. SO
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE US SOME
COMMENTARY AROUND THOSE ISSUES.
SURE A GREAT GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO I WAS BASICALLY
TRYING TO GET YOU TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE WELL ABSOLUTELY AND
YOU BRING UP SOME SOME CRITICAL
ISSUES AND THESE ARE NOT EASY
ISSUES THERE ARE STICKY AND
THEY DO REQUIRE A- SOCIETY
LEVEL- YOU KNOW THESE ARE
GENERATIONAL SHIFTS IN THE WAY
WE DO THINGS IN CALIFORNIA
ALONG THE LINES OF
RESTRUCTURING ITSELF FOR. YOU
KNOW- YOU KNOW THIS THESE ARE
LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE
TRANSITIONS THEY HAVE TO HAPPEN
OVER MANY YEARS AND DECADES-
AND SO. SO I AGREE WITH YOU
KNOW I THINK OUR NOTICES SHOWS
THAT- AND THAT'S IT IT
CORRELATES- WELL WITH WHAT
DOCTOR WERE PRESENTED- THAT
THERE WERE LIKE ON A TRIP AND
THIS IS A PRETTY ROBUST.
CONCLUSION REGARDLESS OF THE
CHANGES AN ABSOLUTE VOLUMES OF
NATURAL GAS PROJECT READ THAT
WITH LOTS OF ELECTRIFICATION
INCLUDING ON THE TRANSPORTATION
SIDE AS WELL AS ELECTRIFICATION
OF BUILDINGS. THE THERE WILL BE
SOME OPPORTUNITY FOR DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON ELECTRIC RATES
RIGHT NOW LIKE THE BRITS ARE
HIGH IN THE INVESTMENT UTILITY
TERRITORIES WILL NOW- AND- GAS
RATES ARE RELATIVELY. LOW AND
SO WE'RE AT THIS POINT WHERE
THERE'S NOT QUITE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE TO EMPHASIZE EFFICIENT I
WENT TO THE KITCHEN- BUT- WE'RE
ON A TRAJECTORY WHERE THE GAS
RATES ARE LIKELY TO GO UP MORE
QUICKLY THAN ELECTRIC RATES AND
AT SOME POINT THOSE CROSS. SO
AGAIN HAVE BEEN DOING THAT AND
OPTIMAL WAY REQUIRES VERY A LOT
OF ATTENTION- AND A LOT OF
BOOKS LOCALIZER SPECIFIC
PLANNING. BUT I WILL SAY JUST
TO CONCLUDE WE ARE DOING A FAIR
AMOUNT A LOT ACTUALLY- HYDROGEN
ARE EMPTY AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION ON SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES LIKE LANDING IN THE
SYSTEM. ARE WORKING WITH SO CAL
GAS ON ON SEVERAL PROJECTS
THERE'S SOME REALLY GREAT STUFF
ON HYDROGEN HAPPENING IN LA
PARTICULARLY THE HIGH DEAL.
THEY'RE MAKING SOME PROGRESS
THERE- BUT AGAIN YOU KNOW IF
WE'RE LIMITING THIS TO
BUILDINGS- I THINK THEY'RE
HARDLY CONVERSATION REALLY IS A
BROADER MORE. IN THAT OTHER END
USES- WILL KIND OF BE THE
FIRST- GATEWAY TO. TO FINDING
THOSE HIGH VALUE APPLICATIONS
FOR HYDROGEN AND FOR OUR
ENERGY. INDUSTRIAL AND
TRANSPORTATION- THE WHITE ALL
RIGHT I'LL JUST ONE FINAL O
THIS THAT EXTREME AMOUNTS OF MY
AND YOU BETTER KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
DOING YOU TRY AND PHASE IT OUT
WE ALL AGREE ON THAT- AND RIGHT
NOW IT'S JUST A CONCEPT GOING
TO BRING UP ONE OTHER POINT.
YESTERDAY THE ENERGY INSTITUTE
AT HAAS- SEVERIN BORENSTEIN AND
JAMES BUSHNELL- GAVE A VERY.
INTERESTING WEAPON ARE
ESSENTIALLY IT WAS A SYMPOSIUM
UNIVERSITY SYMPOSIUM LEVEL TALK
ON THE SOCIAL MARGINAL COST OF
ELECTRICITY VERSUS NATURAL GAS.
C. I'LL SEND YOU ONE AS WELL
BUT JUST ASKING I'VE NEVER
GOTTEN A QUANTITATIVE ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION WHY IS THE PRICE
TWICE AS HIGH IF WE UNDERSTOOD
AT LEAST WITH OTHER STAND NOT
THAT WE COULD NECESSARILY
REDUCE IT. NOW THE- THE
PROFESSORS BROUGHT ABOUT A
NUMBER OF WAYS WHERE WE COULD
FIX THE PROBLEM SO ONE OF THEM
WAS JUST TO SUBSIDIZE THE COST
OF ELECTRICITY FROM THE GENERAL
FUND I DON'T THINK THEY'LL BE
TOO MANY VOTES FOR THAT HERE.
UNLESS YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF A SPECIAL SOURCE
OF MONEY- IDEALLY IT WOULD BE
FOR THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS BUT WE ALREADY
KNOW THERE ARE MANY MORE CALLS
ON THAT MONEY THAN ACTUALLY
EXIST ANOTHER WAY TO DO THIS
WOULD BE DO- SIMPLY LOOK AT THE
COST OF THE FIXED COST VERSUS
VARIABLE COST SO ANYONE WHO IS
USING ELECTRICITY WOULD PAY THE
FIXED COST EVERY MONTH WHICH IS
PRETTY HIGH IT'S ABOUT SEVENTY
DOLLARS A MONTH BUT THEN YOUR
VARIABLE COSTS WOULD GO DOWN
BUT IT ANY RIGHT THAT WOULD
HAVE THE EFFECT OF THE USE OF
ELECTRICITY. BEING LESS
EXPENSIVE YOUR YOUR LARGER COST
IS PROBABLY THE FIXED COSTS AND
THE USE WOULD BE THAN LESS
EXPENSIVE YOU'D THEN BE ABLE
TO. ELECTRICITY COULD COMPETE
PRICE WISE. THAT WAS ONE OF
THEIR SUGGESTIONS- FOUGHT SO.
HOW DO WE GET THE RIGHT PRICE
SIGNAL TO USERS OF ELECTRICITY.
SO I'LL JUST VERY BRIEFLY-
PROVIDED ONE COMMENT IN
PARTICULAR OVER TO RESTAURANTS
INTO A PERHAPS AS A AS WELL I
WE'RE VERY FAMILIAR WITH WITH
SEVEN TO WORK ON THIS I WOULD
ACTUALLY HIGHLIGHTED SOME OF
OUR BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
WORK- FUND IT ALSO INTEGRATE
WEEK YES WE INTEGRATE ENERGY
COSTS THE REPORT AND- YEAH AND
OUR OUR YOU KNOW I THINK THERE
ARE THERE'S A VERY LEGITIMATE
STRUCTURAL QUESTIONS HERE OF
COURSE RATE MAKING IS THAT I'M
AT THE RESTAURANT UNTIL THESE
BY THE UC AND SO. I DO KNOW
THAT THEY ARE. LOOKING AT SHE'S
AROUND THIS TOPIC TODAY YEAH AS
WELL AS ON BOTH ELECTRIC SIDE
EMMA GAS SIDE- I GUESS I AM
LOOKING AT SORT OF WHAT THE
COMPONENTS OF THE RATE BASE ARE
FOR PER NEW INSTALLATIONS OF
GAS FOR EXAMPLE. DIGGING INTO
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES THAT
APPROACH- ARE REFERRED TO- BUT
PRICING IS AN ONGOING- SORT OF
YOU KNOW DANCE IN THIS
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT THAT-
YOU KNOW MONOPOLY. THAT
REGULATORY BUT I FULLY
REGULATED AND IN THE END THEIR
COMMISSIONS- HAVE TO WRESTLE
WITH AND I THINK HAVING THIS
BROADER CONVERSATION ABOUT OUR
POLICY DIRECTION. WILL IS
ESSENTIAL TO HELP PROVIDE A
FRAMEWORK IN WHICH THAT CAN
HELP WITH CLEAR INTENTION TO
MEET OUR LONG TERM CARBON
REDUCTION GOALS- AND YOU KNOW
IN THE STATE WE HAVE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES AND GAS UTILITIES AND
THOSE TO SOMEHOW NEED TO HAVE A
CROSSWALK. SO WHAT WITHOUT ANY
PETS THAT'S GOING TO WEAR ON IT
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
RIGHT I'VE ONE LAST QUESTION
THE AND THEN I'LL HOWEVER MY
COLLEAGUES SO OKAY WITH THE
COMPRESSOR RIGHT COULD COULD
THAT TIME AND THERE'S A LOT I
DIDN'T QUITE GIVE IT A FULL
ANSWER THE SECOND ONE ONE THING
IN RESPONSE TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK'S QUESTION I THINK IT'S A
REALLY VALID QUESTION AND
THERE'S THAT SORT OF BASIC
ISSUE AROUND. WHAT WE INCLUDE
AN ELECTRIC RATES AND WHAT WE
RECOVER FROM TAXPAYERS OTHER
OTHER SOURCES IN OTHER WAYS
AND- I THINK IT RELIGION THE
QUESTIONS TO BE ASKED ABOUT
WHETHER. EVERYTHING WE'RE
GETTING FROM ELECTRIC RATES
SHOULD BE THERE OR WHETHER YOU
KNOW MAYBE THE GENERAL FUND IS
THE RIGHT PLACE TO BE LOOKING
OR THE G. CARE ACT AS YOU
SUGGESTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORK-
ANOTHER QUESTION THAT- I THINK
WE NEED TO GET RIGHT. INVOLVES
HOW THE TO THE STRUCTURE OF
RATES AND HOW RATES ARE COVERED
IN AND PROFESSOR BORNSTEIN AND
BUSH KNOWLEDGE MADE SOME
INTERESTING SUGGESTIONS THEY'VE
ALSO MADE INTERESTING
SUGGESTIONS PERSPECTIVE ST
ENERGY RESOURCES. RECENTLY. AND
I THINK ALL OF THIS ON YOU KNOW
WITHOUT ENDORSING YOU I THINK
WE NEED TO BE THINKING AS A
STATE VERY CAREFULLY BECAUSE WE
HAVE FACE SOME REALLY
UNPRECEDENTED CRISES IN THE
POWER SECTOR AS WE ALL NOW AND
WE ALL HAD TO DEAL WITH OVER
THE LAST FIVE TO TEN YEARS-
DOES IT RAISE COSTS AND WE'RE
APPROACHING IN A CERTAIN WAY-
AND DOES HAPPEN THOSE COSTS ARE
PASSED THROUGH TO RAISE RATES
TO RATE PAYERS. AND SO I GUESS
THE THING THAT I WOULD SAY THAT
THE CLAIM THAT I WOULD STAKE IS
THAT WE DO NEED TO BE THINKING
HOLISTICALLY AND I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT. MY SENSE IS NOT THE
COMMISSION. RCT ENERGY
COMMISSION THE P. YOU SEE ANY
ISO. ARE WORKING TOGETHER TO
TRY TO FIGURE THIS OUT AND TO
THINK HOLISTICALLY ABOUT THIS
PROBLEM. THE ON BOX FROM RATES
THIS YEAR WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IN FURTHERING THAT
CONVERSATION. THE STAFF WHITE
PAPER IN PARTICULAR ALSO WAS
VERY HELPFUL. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION IN CALIFORNIA
TRYING TO WORK TOWARD SOLUTIONS
BUT IT IS NOT EASY YEAH AND-
AND- THAT'S PROBABLY GOOD. YEAH
I THINK WE CAN ALL GET RESERVE
ID'S SO THE MUCH STATEMENT THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW THE RELATIVE
TRAJECTORIES OF GAS ELECTRIC
RATES- ACTUALLY CAME FROM THE
WORK THAT WAS ELABORATE AROUND
THAT ON BALK AT SOME OF THE
WORK TO BE DONE. THE COMMISSION
SO- SO I THINK THAT MIGHT BE
THAT THE- THE ENERGY AGENCIES
ARE ACUTELY AWARE OF THIS. AND
THE ISSUE OF A LIABILITY THAT
IS FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR YEAH AND
IT GENERAL I PART OF THE HERE
WILL BE POLITICAL AND WHATEVER
WE DO- BUT WE'D WE'D APPRECIATE
GETTING SOME INFORMATION FROM
THE AGENCIES AND SOME
SUGGESTIONS ON DIRECTIONS TO GO
AND- WE DON'T HAVE THAT
EXPERTISE HERE THE FINAL
QUESTION I'M GONNA RAISE A
CONCERN THAT I KNOW I'VE TALKED
WITH THE CHAIROF THE
COMMISSION A NUMBER OF TIMES
YOU HAVE MANDATED- SOLAR ON NEW
BUILDINGS. YOU'RE ABOUT TO
MANDATE EVEN MORE SOLAR IF THE
NEWS ARTICLES I'M READING ARE
CORRECT THE PROBLEM IS AND I
KNOW THE P. YOU SEE IS LOOKING
AT. AT THE- AT THE WAY IN WHICH
SUBSIDIZED BUT IT'S SUBSIDIZED
TO A FAIRLY LARGE XM SEVERIN
BORENSTEIN ESTIMATES THAT ITS
TWO CENTS A KILOWATT HOUR NOW
FOR EVERY CUSTOMER. FOR THE
SUBSIDY SIMPLY FOR THE
RESIDENTIAL MA'AM THAT WE'VE
BEEN. DOING AND IT COULD BECOME
A LOT LARGER AND I'M HOPING
BEFORE YOU MAKE THIS DECISION
TO FIRST OF ALL IT'S JUST.
CHEAPER TO DO UTILITY SCALE
SOLAR AND SO TO MANDATE IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY GIVE US MORE
SOLAR ENERGY BECAUSE WE'VE
ALREADY SAID WE'RE GOING TO. GO
TO A 100% RENEWABLES RELATIVELY
AND CHANCES ARE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE THAT DATE UP. EVEN CLOSER
TO THE CURRENT TIME SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO ALL RENEWABLE
ENERGY WHY ARE WE THOUGHT WHY
THEN ARE YOU AND MAYBE YOU'VE
GOT A GOOD REASON I DON'T KNOW.
WHY THEY'RE YOU MANDATING THAT
THE B. BUT BE DONE IN THE MOST
EXPENSIVE WAY POSSIBLE ONE OF
OUR BIG PROBLEMS WITH
CONVERTING OVER TO ELECTRICITY
IS SIMPLY THE HIGH COST. SO
THANKS FOR THAT QUESTION I'M
I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT
WITH PROFESSOR FOR INSTANCE-
VIEWS ON THIS WE HAVE WE HAVE.
SOME BACK AND FORTH
PERIODICALLY ABOUT THIS- AND I
AM. YOU KNOW AS THE LEAGUE
COMMISSIONER ON THE BUILDING
CODE NO I SHEPHERD THIS THESE
PACKAGES EVERY THREE YEARS- AND
WE JUST AS YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BUILDING
CHARACTER EXPANSE PEAVEY.
REQUIREMENT MODESTLY BUT IT
DOES EXPAND INTO SOME OF YOUR
NON RESIDENTIAL SOME
NONRESIDENTIAL CATEGORIES IN
ADDITION TO THAT SINGLE FAMILY
SO THERE ARE BENEFITS ACTUALLY
TO DOING IT IN A DISTRIBUTED
WAY VERSUS- UTILITY SCALE AND
SO. AND THIS ISN'T AN EITHER OR
IT'S- IT'S ABOUT WITH ME AND WE
NEED WE NEED LARGE SCALE AND WE
NEED DISTRICTS- AND- WE IN THE
NEXT FINANCIAL INTO THE
NONRESIDENTIAL CATEGORIES WE
ACTUALLY HEAR THAT WITH BATTERY
SYSTEMS. IN OUR ANALYSIS SHOWS
THAT THIS IS VERY COST
EFFECTIVE UNDER CURRENT RATES
CERTAINLY FOR END USERS POSTS
BOTH RESIDENTIAL. AND
NONRESIDENTIAL- BUT THAT EVEN
UNDER SO. WIDE ARRAY OF
SCENARIOS FOR FUTURE RIGHTS.
GIVEN GIVEN THAT THE DECLINING
COSTS OF SOLAR THE IN DECLINE
ACROSS THE STORE AS WELL THAT
THIS WILL REMAIN THE CASE IN IN
NEAR FUTURE IN IN THE LONG TERM
WITH THE WITH THESE RESOURCE
BEING YES THEY WERE SO I WILL
JUST POINT OUT THERE IS A LOT
OF FLEXIBILITY IN THE WAY THAT
THOSE SORTS REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING OPINION STORAGE BE
PARTICULARLY ARE FIVE AND SO IF
THE BUILDING IS- HAS A
FOOTPRINT WHAT DOESN'T. ALLOW
FOR THAT MUCH SPACE AND THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT MULTI FAMILY AND
NON RESIDENTIAL ALLOW FOR SOLAR
ON THE ROOF AND THERE ARE SOME
EXEMPTIONS THERE. ALSO THERE'S
A COST EFFECTIVENESS OUT WHERE.
CITY UTILITY OF A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FILES WITH US TO SAY
HEY THAT'S NOT COST EFFECTIVE-
SO. FOR EXAMPLE IT RATES REALLY
JUST. NEVER WENT AWAY
COMPLETELY DO I COMPLETELY THAT
THERE CAN'T GET THEIR A THERE'S
A PATHWAY ACTUALLY GET AN EXAM
FOR THAT REQUIREMENT IN THE
BUILDING CODE AND THAT'S WE DID
THAT WE WORK THROUGH THAT AND
SHE WITH STATE SO THERE'S A
RESILIENCE TO HAVING
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES-
IF THAT DOES HAVE VALUE- AND SO
OVER TIME AS WE HAVE BOTH SMALL
SCALE DISTRIBUTED SOLAR
STORAGE. AND AGREE THAT WE ALSO
NEED LARGE SCALE- YEAH WHICH
STORAGE AS WELL- WILL WILL BE-
ON BOTH ENDS OF THE SYSTEM WILL
HAVE MORE ROBUST- GREAT WELL DO
YOU HAVE A STUDY THAT SHOWS
WHAT THE SAVINGS ARE BY PUTTING
IT ON A ROOF AS OPPOSED TO OUR
OR AT LEAST THE COST TRADE OFFS
BECAUSE FRANKLY I DON'T BELIEVE
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SAFE ABLE TO
SAVE MUCH IN TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION BECAUSE YOU HAVE
THE LOCAL SOLAR IF ANYTHING
THERE COULD BE ADDITIONAL COSTS
BECAUSE YOU'RE GENERATING THAT
AT THE WRONG TIME OF DAY. AND
THE OTHER THING IS YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE RENTAL HOMES LIKE
THE ONE I LIVE IN I LIVE IN A
LARGE RENTAL. APARTMENT AND
YEAH BE SUBSIDIZING THE
HOMEOWNERS AND I JUST DON'T
THINK THAT'S FAIR BUT IF YOU
CAN SHOW ME ECONOMICALLY WILL
WORK PLEASE SEND ME THE
INFORMATION
WE DO KNOW IS THAT FROM THE
POINT OF VIEW OF THE CONSUMER
UNDER A VAST ARRAY OF. SO- BUT
I'M HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN A DEEPER
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS- WHAT IS
THE TO STOP BECAUSE I THINK WE
JUST GO BACK AND FORTH WITH
THAT. WE NEED SOMETHING
QUANTITATIVE BUT I WILL SAY
THIS IS ONLY COST EFFECTIVE FOR
THE PEOPLE TO BUY SOLAR BECAUSE
OTHER PEOPLE PAY THE COSTS AND
I THINK WE COULD GO BACK AND
FORTH ON THIS BUT UNLESS WE GET
SOMETHING QUANTITATIVE. I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE AN ANSWER. AND IF
I COULD I'M ACTUALLY I DON'T
YEAH I THINK IT'S- A BIG DOCTOR
COURT PUT A NICE FIVE POINT ON
THAT AND I THINK IT IS REQUIRE
FOR PROBABLY SOME ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATION IF I COULD GO AND
I AND I WILL GIVE. ALL OF YOU A
CHANCE TO MAKE SOME CLOSING
COMMENTS IF YOU CAN MAYBE HOLD.
YOUR THOUGHT OF THAT BECAUSE I
DO WANT TO TURN TO SOME OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS WHO DO HAVE
QUESTIONS THAT THEY'D LIKE TO
DEPOSE AND SO SURE RIVAS THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE PANELISTS TOWN FOR
THEIR PRESENTATIONS AND- THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THINK OF WHAT.
HOW DO WE DECARBONISE EXISTING
BUILDINGS- THAT'S WHAT I'VE
BEEN THINKING OF IN. YOU KNOW I
HAVE BEEN FOCUSED THIS YEAR. ON
IN EXTREME HEAT- BELL BUT-
STRATEGY FOR THE STATE- THANK
YOU TO JOSE- FOR BRINGING THAT
UP- DURING HIS PRESENTATION OF
BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT HEAT THIS YEAR AND VERY
TIMELY BECAUSE OF THE RECENT
HEAT WAVES ALL OVER. I'M NOT
JUST IN OUR STATE- BUT YOU KNOW
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
THAT. TRADITIONALLY DO NOT
HAVE- EXTREME ENDS FOCUS MY
COMMENTS ON THE COOLING SIDE OF
D. CARBON IT DECARBONIZING
BUILDINGS AND I KNOW SOME OF
YOU TALKED ABOUT HEAT PUMPS AND
OTHER ALTERNATIVES TO AIR
A LOT OF- RESIDENTS. AND
BUILDINGS THATDON'T HAVE AIR
CONDITIONING RIGHT NOW AND I
THINK OF THAT A LOT OF THE LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS- THAT ARE
LEAST LIKELY TO HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE ANY TYPE OF
COOLING. I'VE AND- AND IF WE
THINK OF A STRATEGY OF LIKE
OKAY HOW DO WE PROVIDE COOLING.
I DON'T THINK IT NECESSARILY
HAS TO BE AIR CONDITIONING I
THINK WE CAN ACHIEVE. BOTH
GOALS RIGHT OF THE
DECARBONIZING EXISTING
BUILDINGS AND- PROVIDING.
COOLING YOU KNOW AND I AND
BECAUSE OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE HEALTH EFFECTS. OF SO OF IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW I THINK OF AN
OPPORTUNITY OF EXISTING
BUILDINGS MAYBE WHEN THEY'RE
LOOKING TO UPGRADE OR THEY HAVE
TO REPLACE THEIR EXISTING- AIR
CONDITIONING SYSTEM WHAT CAN WE
DO TO IN EITHER INCENTIVIZE OR
PROMOTE- ANOTHER FORM OF
CHOLINE OR DO WE NEED MORE
RESEARCH IN THIS AREA OF. NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WILL REPLACE
OUR EXISTING AIR CONDITIONING
SYSTEMS THAT'S THOSE ARE
SYSTEMS THAT THERE HAS BEEN
VERY LITTLE INNOVATION OVER THE
YEARS RIGHT I IMAGINE THIS IS
THE SAME WAY THAT WE CALL THE
BUILDING THAT WE DID FIFTY
YEARS AGO AND SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS ON. COMMENTS ON BACK
FROM ANY OF THE PANELISTS.
HOLDEN OKAY NOW SHOULD I WAIT
PLEASE JUMP IN I THANK THE
REVIEWER REFERENCED IN THE
CHASE- ADDITIONAL COMMENTS YEAH
JERRY WEST THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE QUESTION COMMENTS
AROUND EXTREME HEAT AND AGAIN
WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE ALL YOUR WORK
ON THE ISSUE- I THINK. YEAH IT
IS EXTREME HEAT IS UP YOU KNOW
SOMETHING IS CHANGING FAST AND
IT'S ONLY GONNA GET WORSE SO I
AGREE THAT- TAKING DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES AND APPROACH IT FROM
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES IS
IMPORTANT WAITED TO TACKLE
RIGHT AND I THINK. YOU KNOW
WHEN I UP LATE- SO THE WORK
THAT YOU ALL ARE DOING AND SAID
HI NAY PAN RIGHT IT THINK IT'S
FOR COMMUNITY CENTER- AND WE
THINK THAT'S THAT'S A GOOD
APPROACH RIGHT SPECIALLY BURKE-
YOU KNOW SOME MEDIUM LONG TERM
RIDLEY TENSELY SIX FORTUNATELY
RIGHT BUT IF WE THINK IN
ADDITION TO THAT- YOU KNOW AT
THAT. KEEP ON SPACE HEATING BE
THAT SHORT TERM RELIEF TO LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES TO YOUR POINT RIGHT
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO. WAIT FOR
THAT KIND OF RETREAT RIGHT AS
THINGS GET WORSE ESPECIALLY IN
PLACES WHERE THEY NEED IT ALL
RIGHT- AND I THINK- GOING BACK
TO THE- DOCTOR WORKERS AND
WEBER WORKS COMMENTS AND KEEP
MY SPACE IN IT RIGHT UP SOME OF
THE ATHLETES STUDIES
DEMONSTRATE- CLEARLY IN THERE
THAT YOU KNOW THERE IS. OUT.
YEAH EITHER SOME STATE OR A TO
FOUR DOLLARS WHEN YOU HAVE IT
HE PUTS BASS AND ENCONTRA TO
THE TRADITIONAL SO I THINK PER
I BRING THAT UP TO THAT WHY
THERE'S A FOCUS YOU KNOW ON
PLANTS BECAUSE WE FEEL LIKE
THAT THE DISCUSS IT'S SOMETHING
WHERE IS SOMETHING THAT AND OUT
MUCH EASIER RIGHT IN AND WORK
OUT MY BETTER FOR BOTH THAT
NEED MOST WENT OF HEAT OF SPACE
AND SO WE THAT'S WHY IT'S IN
ORDER TO GET THE MARKET GOING.
TO GET THAT WORKFORCE- AND THE
STABILITY. TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
ACROSS THAT DR WHERE ANOTHER
STOP ON TERMS OF THAT SEXUAL
TRIMMING. WE THINK HE FARMS ARE
ONE WAY TO KIND OF START
INVESTING FUNDING NOT ONLY TO
KIND OF GET TO THAT LONG TERM
APPROACH THAT'S THE BEST
APPROACH- BUT ALSO TO START.
BUILDING THAT MARKET
INSTABILITY NOW IN PROVIDING
THOSE BENEFITS THE COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED IT MOST- SO I HOPE
THAT. YOU KNOW INTEREST YOUR
QUESTION ON THIS BUT I THINK
THAT SPEAKING WITH. CORPORATE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS INCLUDING
YOURSELF REQUESTED THE
FOURTEENTH ISSUE THANK YOU I
GAVE THOSE AND I THINK THIS OF
WE HAVE TO CA WORKING ON IT AND
INVOLVING- GROUPS THAT
REPRESENT ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND AS YOU
MENTIONED LIKE THE GROUPS THAT
ARE WORK THAT HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR THE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE HUBS I THINK THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO. TO ALSO
EDUCATE OUR PEOPLE ON OF MORE
EFFICIENT TECHNOLOGIES FOR
COOLING AND HEATING SO THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER MEMBERS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO POSE ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME. I JUST
SAID- AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT I JUST HAD A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS REAL QUICK
FOR MISS KUMAR- WATER IN YOUR
ESTIMATION THE MAJOR COST
BARRIERS AND IMPACTS TO RENTERS
AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES. AND
HOUSEHOLDS WHEN ELECTRIFYING
MULTI FAMILY BUILDINGS AND THEN-AND THEN AND THE FOLLOW UP
QUESTION IS WHAT WOULD YOU
SUGGEST OR ARE THERE ANY
CHALLENGES TO DECARBONISING
MULTI FAMILY HOMES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS. THAT
CAN BE ADDRESSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. YET HERE ARE SOME
OF THE MAJOR SEARCH ON THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION SITE BE ARE SAYING
THAT IT'S LARGELY COST NEUTRAL
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS TO DO THIS WORK AND
ON THE NEW CAR- ON THE EXISTING
BUILDING SIDE JUST A SHORT
AMOUNT OF WORK AND THE LIMITED
OPERATING BUDGET THAT THEY'RE
ALL CHAD ITSELF POSES A
PROBLEM. AND AS I SAID I THINK
OF THE WEIGHT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCING SYSTEM IS SET
UP IS PROBLEMATIC AS WELL
BECAUSE IN A LOT OF INSTANCES
BRANCH YOU OF SWITCHING CAN GET
COMPLICATED AND TRICKY WHERE
ESPECIALLY IN CENTRAL DOMESTIC
OPERATOR HEATING IS WHERE WE
ARE SEEING AN ISSUE RIGHT NOW
IN EXISTING BUILDINGS. SO TO
REPLACE THAT THERE SEEMS TO BE
A LOT MORE WORK THAT'S NEEDED
AND LAUDABLE AS IT REALLY
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT WORK
AND I THINK ONE OF TE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES JUST GETTING FUNDING
TO COVER AT LEAST A PORTION OF
IT. AND I WOULD SAY SO THE MAIN
BATTERY ENERGY SOMETIMES A COST
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROVIDERS HAS JUST BEEN. YOU
KNOW AS A SWAPPING OUT CENTER
MYSTIC OPERATING SYSTEMS. AND
DAUGHTERS DATA COMMITTEES IS
JUST PROVIDING A LOT MORE
FUNDING TO COVER THAT COST WHAT
IT IS TO COVER GAPS FUNDING.
AND AS I SAID PANEL UPGRADES
AND TRANSFORM UPGRADE THROUGH
EARLY OF COULD THE COST CAME TO
SURFACE PROJECT APPEARS TO BE
FEASIBLE AND WILL BE UTILIZED
THAT. YOU KNOW THEY HAVE TO
CHANGE THAT PROBLEM WHICH IN A
LOT OF OLDER PROPERTIES WHICH
IS A LOT OF EXISTING MULTI
FAMILY STOCK. IT IS REALLY OLD
AND FUNDS NEED TO BE UPGRADED
AND WE'RE SEEING THAT THE COST
IS JUST JUMPING ALL OVER THE
PLACE SO WE DON'T HAVE A STEADY
OP OPERATING UP AND LOOKED AT
COST. AND WE ARE I THINK. WE
HEARD IT BEFORE. I THINK REALLY
ALSO FIGURING OUT YOU'RE NOT AN
ELECTRIC FRIENDLY IT WOULD
HELP. HONEST CONSIDER THAT LONG
TERM OPERATING COST AND SEE
POSITIVE OUT INCOME FLOW. AND
THAT COULD REALLY MORE TO READ
MOTIVATE THEM TO DO SOME OF THE
WORK. ASK WOULD RESIDENTS I
THINK THIS IS JUST A VERY
CRITICAL UPGRADE AND CHANGE
REQUESTS SPOKE ABOUT IT I THINK
IT'S NO LONGER A QUESTION OF
WHETHER WE CAN ELECTION FIVE
THAT WE CAN. PUT IN SOME OF
THESE ARE PLANS IS GENERALLY
ESSENTIAL. FOR YOU KNOW LOW
INCOME RENTERS TO JUST LIVE IN
THEIR HOME ESPECIALLY AT A TIME
LIKE THIS WHERE YOU KNOW GOING
OUT IS NOT AN OPTION. FOR A LOT
OF COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OF THE
HEALTH CARE IS THAT GOING ON
CLOSES EITHER BY FIRES ON
MICHAEL WITH. SO A LOT OF.
RESIDENTS I JUST SPENDING TIME
MANAGEMENT I THINK. YOU KNOW IF
THEY'RE NOT DOING THAT I THINGS
LIKE INSTALLING HEAT BOUNDS OF
INSTALLING. AT CONDITIONING I
JUST THINK AND THIS TIME
THEY'RE JUST FOR THE PAST LOW
BASS SO I THINK EARLY GOOD
TRAITS AND REALLY GOOD BATES
THE WAY FARM TO THAT ACTIVITY
AND. THEY WERE TRICKED HER PRE
SHOULD MYSTERY IS ALL GOING BE
CHAO ACROSS THE BOARD AND
CERTAINLY PAYING ATTENTION TO
THE- DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT IT
COULD HAVE ON LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND RENTERS WHO
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
INTEGRATING PROPERLY IN THE
MODELING AS WE GO FORWARD- I
SEE NO OTHER CHERISHED IT'S
THEIR PANEL JOSH GREEN NOT MASS
MARRIAGES I JUST WANTED TO
WEIGH AND- AND ECHO MY FELLOW
PANELISTS UP REMARKS AS RELATES
TO A MULTI FAMILY HOUSING- YOU
KNOW WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE A QUICK
MATH- THE PUMP- CENTRAL HEAT
PUMP EQUIPMENT- THAT IS- BEING
UTILIZED AND MULTI FAMILY-
INSTALLATIONS NOT ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT- IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY AND THERE'S SOME
OTHER MANUFACTURERS AS WELL
THAT. I HAVE A QUICK MATH- BUT
THE UNDERLYING FINANCING AND
WHEN I HAD REFERENCED- IN MY
OPENING REMARKS AND THOSE
INCENTIVES ARE KEY- BECAUSE IT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NASCENT
TECHNOLOGY BUT ALSO LIMITED- IN
FIELD APPLICATIONS IN THESE
INSTALLATIONS SO WE'RE STILL
LEARNING. RIGHT AS AN INDUSTRY-
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT- GREAT ENABLE TECHNOLOGY
THAT WOULD GO ALONG WITH THESE
TYPES OF SYSTEMS- ESPECIALLY
FOR LOAD SHIFTING- THAT- CAN
CERTAINLY HELP THIS WITHOUT
WRITTEN BALANCES THE PROVERBIAL
ETCETERA BUT I JUST WANT TO
HAVE A CERTAINLY ECHO AND
REITERATE THAT THE FINANCING
MECHANISMS AND FLEXIBILITY
THERE ARE GOING TO BE AN VERY
IMPORTANT- WE GET A LOT OF
FEEDBACK IN THIS REGARD
NATIONALLY WITH- ARCHITECTS
SPECIFYING ENGINEERS THAT WE
WORK WITH IN THE COMMERCIAL
SECTOR- THAT'S KEY AND ONE OF
THE THINGS. THAT- COMMISSIONER
CALLOUS THERE TALKED EARLIER ON
WITH PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ASKED- TESTS
TO EXPLORE AND THINK ABOUT. IT
IS VERY SIMILAR TO THE ENERGY
SERVICE COMPANY MODEL RIGHT
ESCO MODEL IN TERMS OF- ENERGY
EFFICIENCY UPGRADES TO
BUILDINGS ARE MOSTLY IN THE
COMMERCIAL SECTOR AND-
PROVERBIAL MUSH MARKET RIGHT
NOW A SIMPLE UNIVERSITIES
SCHOOLS HOSPITALS IS THERE A
ROLE FOR THAT TYPE OF-
FINANCING. OF CORPORATE
PARADIGM FOR MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING ESPECIALLY FOR- SMALLER
OWNERS OF MULTI FAMILY HOUSING-
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE AN
INCENTIVIZED- IN TERMS OF A
LEASING MODEL. SO AGAIN YOU
KNOW FROM A FROM A MANUFACTURER
STANDPOINT AND IN THE FIELD
EXPERIENCE THAT WE HAVE NOW THE
TECHNOLOGY IS THERE AND IT'S
BEGINNING TO GROW AND ADAPT AND
INNOVATE- BUT TO REALLY- MAKE
UP BREAK AND A MULTI HOUSE IN
OUR DAUGHTER INCOME TO- WITH
WITH RENTERS WE'RE GOING TO
NEED SOME MORE FLEXIBILITY ON
THE FINANCING PARADIGMS THANK
YOU A TOFU PERSICA I WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT- DO WE
HAVE BY LOOKING AROUND I DON'T
SEE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WHO'S
HERE TO PROVIDE COMMENT- WILL
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE DUE TO
ONGOING CO IN NINETEEN SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS WE WILL NEED TO
PLACE A TIME LIMIT ON PUBLIC
TESTIMONY I'M NOT SURE HOW MANY
WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE NOT IN THE
QUEUE OKAY SO WE CAN- SKIP OVER
THE- WITNESS PRESENTATIONS THE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP DANNY INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE- ON LINE WE WERE LIKE 2%
PUBLIC COMMENT IF ANY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LIKE THAT HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN THAT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND WE HAVE ABOUT
TWELVE IN Q. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANK YOU MICHAEL BOOKER
TOMORROW ON THE AFTER THE ACT
UNDER G. CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AND- WHAT WEFULLY
RECOGNIZE THAT MOST OF THE
DISCUSSION TODAY HAS BEEN ON
THE RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL
BUILDING SECTOR. THERE HAS
BEEN- REPEATED MENTION- IN THIS
DISCUSSION AND OTHER
DISCUSSIONS ARE TAKING PLACE
ABOUT THE MANUFACTURING. AND
FOOD PROCESSING SECTOR A SECTOR
THAT'S OFTEN REFERRED TO AS THE
HARD TO ELECTRIFY SECTOR
CALIFORNIA. ANDI REALLY WANT
TO FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON THAT- I
NOTICED BIG SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAS COMPANY HAS CONTINUED TO
PRESS THE ISSUE OF
DECARBONISATION OF THE
PIPELINE. AS A SOLUTION AND I
THINK I AGREE WITH MR QUIRK
THAT IT MAY HAVE SOME.
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS MAY HAVE
SOME LIMITED CAPACITY AND
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS. IT IS NOT- RENEWABLE
GAS IS NOT I REPEAT A SOLUTION
IN THE MANUFACTURING SECTOR.
RENEWABLE GASES FIVE TO TEN
TIMES MORE EXPENSIVE
CONTENTION. CONVENTIONAL FOSSIL
GAS. AND IT'S JUST NOT AN
ECONOMIC SOLUTION UNLIKE THE
GAS COMPANY WE DON'T GET TO
PASS ON A 100% OF OUR COPS. WE
CERTAINLY DON'T GET A
GUARANTEED RATE OF RETURN OF
10% AND EVERY INVESTMENT YOU'VE
MADE. IF WE DID WE WOULDN'T BE
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION RIGHT
NOW. WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
COMPETE AND SO IT'S GOING TO BE
VERY IMPERATIVE AS. WE MOVE
DOWN THIS PATH I SINGLE LECTURE
CASE AND RENEWABLE ARE NOT
SOLUTIONS IN THE HARD TO
ELECTRIFY SECTOR BECAUSE OF
COST AND OTHER CONSIDERATIONS.
WE NEED TO FIND SOLUTIONS FOR
THAT SECTOR THAT OUR ECONOMIC
AN OLD LOVE THE SECTORS TO
CONTINUE TO PROSPER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE OUR VIEWS HOPEFULLY WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
DISCUSSION RATHER THAN
CONTINUING TO PLAY THIS GAME.
THAT RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AND
DECARBONISATION PIPELINE IS
GOING TO BE A- SOLUTION FOR US.
AND THEN FINALLY ELECTRIC RATES
ARE MORE THAN DOUBLE P. JUNE
ELECTRIC RATES ARE QUICKLY
MOVING TOWARDS THREE TIMES THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE BUT THE-
LATEST RATE INCREASE PROPOSALS
THEY'VE UNVEILED IN THE CONCEPT
OF UNDERGROUNDING TEN. THOUSAND
MILES OF THEIR TRANSMISSION
LINES. WHICH WILL COST AN
ESTIMATED THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S THE SAME PRICE
TAG BUT I THINK YOU HEARD
PROFESSOR LAURA. PUT ON- THE-
ELECTRIFICATION OF ALL
BUILDINGS IN THE STATE SO.
THAT'S A HUGE CONCERN FOR US
AND WE NEED TO GET ELECTRICITY
PRICES UNDER CONTROL AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU STE. OUR
NEXT RECORD. THANK THANK YOU
WELCOME A YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANK YOU GERALDINE ENSURE
RIVAS- I'M PAUL BREMER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN CBRE
SPONSORED STUDY THAT LOOKED AT
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
POTENTIAL OF NEW HOMES VERSUS
EXISTING HOMES. MY IS THE CIVIC
LEE- WE LOOKED AT THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS THAT
COULD BE MADE FROM A FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN A
NEW HOME- BUILT IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN- VERSUS A SIMILAR HOME
IT WAS CONSTRUCTED IN NINETEEN
NINETY AND THE RESULTS WERE
STUNNING- THE FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR INVESTMENT RESULTED IN
EIGHT. TIMES THE GHG REDUCTIONS.
AND THE OLDER HOME THEN IN THE
NEW ONE. AND KEEP IN MIND THE
STUDY WAS DONE EIGHT YEARS AGO-
INTO GERMAN HOLDEN'S POINT- WE
ONLY LOOKED AT ENERGY
EFFICIENCY BACK THERE- I
REALIZE A LECTOR VACATION HAS
REALLY COME ON STRONG RECENTLY
BUT- AT THE TIME WE DID THIS
STUDY WE ONLY LOOKED AT ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. AND KEEP IN MIND
ALSO THAT THE CDC HAS UPDATED
ITS ENERGY RAW STANDARDS THREE
MORE TIMES- INCLUDING THE
ROOFTOP SOLAR MANDATE THAT TOOK
EFFECT. IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY SO- WHY WE'VE YET TO
UPDATE THE STUDY I IT'S SAFE TO
ASSUME. THAT THE SAME FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR INVESTMENT
TODAY WOULD READ FAR GREATER
RESULTS- THAN IT DID IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN NOW CAN WE
REDO A FURTHER REDUCE GHG
EMISSIONS A NEW HOMES OF
COURSE- IT'S JUST GOING TO COST
A LOT MORE- DUE TO DIMINISHING
RETURNS. AND IS COMMISSION
MCALISTER'S ALREADY SAID
THERE'S ENORMOUS GHG REDUCTION
POTENTIAL AND THE EXISTING
BUILDING STOCK- WE ALREADY KNOW
THAT AND IF THE STAFF IS
POINTED. OUT IN THEIR-
BACKGROUND PAPER THERE ARE
SIMPLE IN VERY LOW THINGS THAT
CAN BE TO REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS
AND OLDER HOMES AND APARTMENTS-
COCKING IN CEILING WINDOWS
DOORS WALLS- PUTTING IN
INSULATION WRAP ON THE WATER
HEATER- AND CHECKING THE DUCKS
SYSTEM- FOR LEAKS. ALL OF THESE
ARE VERY LOW COST ITEMS BUT
HAVE HUGE- REDUCTION POTENTIAL
BOTH GHG- INTO YOUR ENERGY BILL
AND REDUCING THE ENERGY BILL OF
COURSE- MEANS MORE MONEY IN THE
POCKET FOR THE CONSUMER- AND
ALSO IS- COMMISSION MCALLISTER
SAID. A COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THE STATE AND THE STAKEHOLDERS
ASSEMBLY KEY TO THE SUCCESS. WE
NEED TO IMPLEMENT A WAY TO KEEP
TRACK OF WHAT UPGRADES ARE
BEING MADE TO THE EXISTING
BUILDING STOCK- AND PERHAPS DO
SOMETHING WHAT WE'RE ALREADY
DOING IN TERMS OF OUR REGISTRY-
WITH ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN NEW
HOME CONSTRUCTION. BUT IF WE
DON'T KEEP TRACK. OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THE EXISTING HOUSING
STOCK TEN YEARS DOWN THE ROAD
WE'RE GONNA BE WONDERING WHERE
DO WE NEED TO BE- MAKING THE
CHANGES AND WHAT CHANGES NEED
TO BE MADE AND LASTLY WE ALSO
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
UPGRADES TO THE EXISTING
BUILDINGS ARE CORRECTLY DONE
AND ARE INSPECTED BY THE LOCAL
BUILDING DEPARTMENTS. THIS IS
BEEN ALL HORRIBLE PROBLEM OVER
THE PAST DECADE- ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO- WE HELP THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS-
DO A SURVEY AND WE FOUND- THAT
UP TO TEN THOUSAND. AIR
CONDITIONING UNITS THAT WERE
SOLD IN THE LA BASIN. FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE HAD PERMITS
TAKEN OUT WHEN THEY WERE
INSTALLED THAT'S LESS THAN 5%
OF THE TOTAL- AND THAT NEEDS TO
CHANGE SO IN CLOSING C. B. I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
WORK WITH THE CDC. THE
LEGISLATURE AND GROUPS LIKE
ENERGY SEE- TO REDUCE GHG
EMISSIONS AND BOTH NEW AND
ESPECIALLY THE EXISTING HOUSING
STOCK THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
GOING TO I'M I BELIEVE THAT THE
PREVIOUS TWO SPEAKERS WERE PART
OF A MAKING OF A MORE STATED
PRESENTATION- I'M GOING TO
SUGGEST GOING FORWARD THAT.
EACH PUBLIC COMMENT SPEAKER HAS
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES- TO
SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS ARE ASKED
A QUESTION. MODERATOR THANK YOU
MEXICO. TICKETS NEED MEXICO
LINE OF NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THANK YOU CHAIRED HOLDEN
RELAPSE AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS YALI AFRICAN I'M
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS WE HAVE THE YOU
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW
THE COPPER HAS THE LETTER THAT
WAS SUBMITTED LAST WEEK FOR
THIS HEARING. OTHER IS ALREADY
BEEN CONSIDERABLE DIALOGUE
TODAY REGARDING THE COST OF
ELECTRICITY AND HEAT PUMP
TECHNOLOGY SO I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO USE THIS MOMENT TO HIGHLIGHT
ONE ADDITIONAL IMPORTANT POINT.
WE ALSO MAKE OUR WATER I TO
BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT THE CURRENT MEDIAN PRICE
OF A HOME IN CALIFORNIA IS OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
MAKING THE STATE'S HOUSING
MARKET ALARMINGLY UNAFFORDABLE.
THE PURSUIT OF ELECTRIFYING
EXISTING HOME TO BE A RETROFIT
ON RETAIL PROGRAM. WILL ONLY
DRIVE UP HOME SALES PRICES AND
FURTHER FRUSTRATE THE HOME
BUYING PROCESS. AND YOU KNOW
AND AS WE HEARD MAJOR POINTS.
REPLACEMENTS WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL WORK. SUCH AS AN
ELECTRICAL PANEL UPGRADES.
WHICH INVOLVES FINDING BIDDING
AND SCHEDULING A PROFESSIONAL
CONTRACTOR INSTALLATION TIME
AND THEN A GOVERNMENT
INSPECTION. THE TIME TO
COMPLETE ANY UPGRADES OR
REPAIRS NEGOTIATED IN A REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTION IS ALREADY
NARROWLY CONSTRAINED BY THE
WINDOW OF TIME. OFFERED BY
BUYERS FINANCING COMPANY. WHICH
IS OFTEN ONLY A THIRTY DAY
WINDOW. TO ADDING ANY
REQUIREMENTS OR TRANSACTIONAL
PUT LOWER AND MIDDLE CLASS
CALIFORNIANS A DISADVANTAGE.
AND THOSE WHO ARE PAYING CASH
FOR HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL DOWN
PAYMENT WILL HAVE MORE
FINANCIAL FLEXIBILITY OVER
THOSE USING CONVENTIONAL.
FINANCING FOR FHA LOANS IN
ADDITION THE REGION AND ONGOING
AND MATERIAL SHORTAGES AND
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES HAVE PUT IN
SHARP RELIEF. NEED TO SHOP
FACTORS THAT WERE ADDED TO THE
DELAYS AND INCREASED COSTS
ASSOCIATED SOCIAIS DID WITH
HOME SALES BASED RETROFIT
MANDATE. TO CONCLUDE THINKING
IN MIND THAT AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD ANY RETROFIT ON RESELL
MANDATE ARE GUARANTEED TO NOT
ONLY PRIVATE HOUSING PROJECT
COSTS. BUT WILL ALSO SEVERELY
DISRUPT THE ABILITY FOR AVERAGE
CALIFORNIANS SUCCESSFULLY BY
HOME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. MAX
SPEAKER. GILBERT TO LINE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
TO POLLING IS VERY INFORMATIVE
HEARING TOGETHER I BOUGHT
THANKS TO MAKE UP HALF THE
PENINSULA CLEAN ENERGY JOINT
POWERS ABILITY TWENTY CITIES
TOWNS IN THE COUNTY BUT A
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATOR
PROGRAM. INSANITARY COUNTY
EXPANDING A LOS PONTOS ANDERSON
COUNTY TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
ACCURATE IN THAT CASE
BACKGROUND DOCUMENT THE
ELECTRICITY SUPPLIED TO
BUILDING STATEWIDE WHICH
CURRENTLY CREATED CONTRIBUTED.
TO BUILDING SECTORS GHG
EMISSIONS PLEASE ARE DEALING
THIS OF AND WHICH WERE PROVIDED
ACOSTA ALL CUSTOMERS WITH A
100% CARBON FREE ENERGY START
TURNING OUR ATTENTION REDUCING
ONSITE EMISSIONS IN MULTIPLE
WAYS. WORKING CLOSELY WITH
HOMEOWNERS LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS TO ELECTRIFY THE
EXISTING BUILDING STOCK IT'S IN
FAMILY HOMES MULTI UNIT
DWELLINGS AND COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS OPERATING INCOME ON
OUR WEBSITE HOW TO DECARBONISE
HOME WRITING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE DESIGNERS AND
FACILITY MANAGERS. MANAGERS ON
ALL ELECTRIC BUILDING
TECHNOLOGIES AND WORKING WITH
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON
BUILDING CODES TO ADVANCE
EDUCATION IN NEW AND EXISTING
BUILDINGS. IN ADDITION THE
INFORMATION PROPER REBATES TO A
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS REPLACE
THEIR NECK AND GAS WATER
HEATERS. PARTISAN CENTERS FOR
ELECTRICAL PANEL UPGRADES AND
ADD ON INCENTIVES FOR CHARACTER
CUSTOMERS. WE KNOW WE NEED TO
DO MORE OUR NEXT AVAILABLE OKAY
DRESSING A CHALLENGE OF RENTAL
UNITS SO DEVELOPING A PILOT.
THREE TO THE NEWS ON THE
FINANCE EDUCATION AT CALTRAIN
NOTED EARLIER. ON BILL
FINANCING SHOWS A LOT OF
PROMISE AS FINANCING COULD BE
TIED TO THE METER AND SURVIVE
CUSTOMER TURNOVER. BUT WE NEED
A SCALED FINANCE SCHOOL TO MAKE
BUILDING RETROFITS PORTABLE.
LASTLY AGREE WITH SEVERAL OF
THE COMMENTS MADE BY
PALESTINIAN ALL HANDS ON DECK
APPROACH. COOPERATION
COORDINATION WHAT ARE COME
HIGHER USE BY BOTH PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC AND BUT FOR THE
COMMITTEE TIRE BANSURI CALIFON
GOALS FOR CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
HER THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS BRAXTON BRIDGERS AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION FOR ENERGY
AFFORDABILITY ALSO KNOWN AS A
WE ARE A FIVE OH ONE C. THREE
NONPROFIT TECHNICAL SERVICES
AND TRAINING ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO ACHIEVING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. GREEN BUILDING
PRACTICES AND DEPLOYMENT OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY RESOURCES AND
NEW AND EXISTING MULTI FAMILY
BUILDINGS. OUR PORTFOLIO
PROGRAMS INCLUDE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM FOR
MULTI FAMILY ALSO KNOWN AS LIVE
LET. AND APPLY WITH MULTI
FAMILY PROGRAM IS A STATEWIDE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
PROGRAM SUPPORTED BY CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS OFFERS INCENTIVES
TO PERFORM DEEP ENERGY
RETROFITS AND SOLAR PEAVEY
INSULATION. LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. SUCH WORK IS
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE NET ZERO
EMISSIONS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
IN A MANNER THAT IS EQUITABLE
AND WHAT'S MORE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO EXPERIENCE. WE
HELD THE FACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
IN THE FORM OF EXTREME HEAT. AS
HE WILL CONTINUE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SERIOUS ILLNESSES AND
DEATHS RELATED TO UNPRECEDENTED
TEMPERATURES ARE EXPECTED TO
INCREASE. AND THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT WILL PERCENT. FORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA HAS A POLICY WORLD
MAP WITH WHICH TO GROUND ITS
WORK TOWARD CARBONITE IN THE
BUILDING SECTOR. RECENTLY THE
CDC RELEASED A BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION ATTACHMENT
COMPLETE WITH STRATEGIES THAT
WILL LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS IN THE
STATE AND CONTINUED FUNDING OF
DECARBONISATION PROGRAMS IS
ESSENTIAL TO THE REALIZATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S EMISSION REDUCTION
GOALS. WITHOUT THE CORPORATE
THE LEGISLATURE AT THE STATE
BUILDING SECTOR WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO UNDERTAKE THE
SUBSTANTIAL. ACHIEVABLE TASK OF
RAPIDLY ELIMINATING EMISSIONS
FROM THE EXISTING BUILDING
STOCK EIGHTY EIGHT COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING OUR WORK AND
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE SOLUTIONS
TO DECARBONISE THE RESIDENTIAL
BUILDING SECTOR. AND WE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS CRITICAL
CONVERSATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU I CAN TELL THE IT SEEMS
LIKE MOST WHO ARE GOING TO BE
PRESENTING THEIR- PUBLIC
COMMENT HAVE PREPARED
STATEMENTS IT APPEARS. AND I'M
GOING TO ASK ONCE AGAIN- IF.
YOU CAN MODIFY IT TO TWO
MINUTES I'M TRYING TO CUT
ANYONE OFF BUT I WILL
APPRECIATE IF YOU CAN MODIFY
YOUR YOUR COM TO FIT A TOMB
TIME FRAME. THANK YOU. NEXT
WEEK YOU ANNEX ABOUT THE LINE
OF THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR HOLDEN
JERRY BUSS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS MARIAN BERGESON
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL THANK YOU FOR
DROPPING THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC-
I JUST WANT YOU KNOW TO POINT
IN RESPONSE TO THE PRESENTATION
TODAY ONE IS- AROUND AND CHERRY
BUT- CHERRY THIS IS LEADERSHIP
ON COOLING. I THINK THE ANY
TIME THE LEGISLATOR THANKS
ABOUT COOLING THEY SHOULD THINK
ABOUT HEATING AS WELL HE PUMPS
CAN DO BOTH THERE'S A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY IN ALL THE NEW
COOLING THAT'S GOING INTO HOMES
OR NEW COOLING THAT'S NEEDED-
TO HAVE HEATING THERE AS WELL
AND THEREBY DISPLACE. THE
FOSSEL- HEATING SOURCES IN HOME
SO JUST THINKING ABOUT THIS
TOGETHER WILL BE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR ANY INCENTIVES-
THE LEGISLATURE IS CONSIDERING.
SECOND REALLY BRIEFLY IT'S JUST
ON HYDROGEN USED IN HOMES I
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT-
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN WOULD
REQUIRE THREE TO SIX TIMES MORE
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY'S BEEN
HITTING THAT SAME HOME WITH A
HIGHLY EFFICIENT HEAT PUMP. IT
ALSO REQUIRES YOU GAS PIPELINES
TO BE REPLACED WITH UPGRADED
PIPES AND APPLIANCES IN THE
HOME IT'S NOT A PRACTICAL
SOLUTION ABOUT HYDROGEN- HAS
BEEN AND PENCIL USES WE SUPPORT
IN THE CONTEXT I'D ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATOR TO FOCUS YOUR
TWO G. ON THURSDAY. USE THAT IN
A SENSE WAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME YOU'RE TO THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU WE'RE YOU
COMMENTS AND WE ARE NOTE THANK
YOU YOUR NEXT OF A LINE OF
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREAT THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN TERRY THIS MY NAME
IS JENNIFER HELFRICH AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF FURIES
WERE IN NONPROFIT. ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AND WE RUN
SOMETHING CALLED THE BUSINESS
FOR INNOVATIVE CLIMATE ENERGY
POLICY OR BY SEVEN AT WORK THAT
THE COALITION OF NEARLY SEVENTY
MAJOR COMPANIES MANY OF WHOM
HAVE SUBSTANTIAL OPERATION OR
HEADQUARTERED IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
HEARING I WANTED TO BRING TO
YOUR ATTENTION THAT OUR
BUSINESS MEMBERS AND PARTNERS
HAVE REPEATEDLY CALLED ON
CALIFORNIA COULD FEEL
AMBITIOUS. BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION POLICIES MOST
RECENTLY IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND AGAIN IN MAY OF THIS
YEAR WE SUBMITTED A LETTER
SIGNED BY FIFTY FIVE BUSINESSES
AND INSTITUTIONS- AND WE PUT IN
THE TITLE TWENTY FOUR DOCUMENT
FIFTY FEET. AND WE CAN SHARE IT
WITH- YOU ALL AFTER THE HEARING
TO THE SIGNATORIES OF THIS
LETTER INCLUDED JLL FORTUNE
FIVE HUNDRED COMMERCIAL REAL
ESTATE SERVICES COMPANY. ADOBE
DIGNITY HEALTH EBAY PAYPAL I
KIA SIERRA NEVADA BREWING
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ARE
YOU TO RECALIBRATE DAVIS VF
CORPORATION AND MANY MORE AND I
JUST WANT YOU ALL TO KNOW THAT
THESE COMPANIES REALLY SUPPORT.
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF ROBUST
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
POLICIES. I AND- EXPLAIN A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY SO-
COMPANIES AND INSTITUTIONS THAT
WE WORK WITH AND IF WE CAN'T
EXCUSE ME I DON'T MEAN TO CUT
YOU OFF- BUT I WOULD PREFER IF
YOU'RE GOING TO FOCUS IN ON ANY
PARTICULAR ELEMENT- THIS IS NOT
A PAID ADVERTISEMENT SO IF YOU
WANT TO JUST. HAVE A COMMENT
YOU HAVE ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS
LEFT- RELATIVE TO THE TO THE-
PRESENTATIONS TODAY THAT WOULD
BE APPRECIATED OTHERWISE. WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT BECAUSE I
GUESS I WOULD JUST SAY THAT-
RELEVANT I THINK THAT OUR
COMPANIES WOULD IT SUPPORT THIS
IN THE CD'S KIND OF THINGS AS A
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITY. THAT THEY
WANT TO MAKE INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA IF WE CAN PURSUE.
POLICIES THAT WILL SUPPORT
DECRIMINALIZATION IN THE
EXISTING BUILDING STOCK THEY
SEE IT AS- AN- ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THE TRAIL SPUR
INNOVATION AND JOBS AND- HELP.
US OUT THERE AND LOOK FORWARD
TO SHARING THE LETTER WITH YOU
LAW AFTER THE HEARING. THANK
YOU SO MUCH X. BAKER THANK YOU
NEXT OVER LINE OF TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON CHAT
HOLDEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
UTILITY ENERGY COMMITTEE. I'M
SORRY I'M ABILITY NIGHT A
DESIGN PROFESSIONAL AND A
RESIDENT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN ORANGE COUNTY. I ALSO SERVE
AS THE DIRECTOR OF
SUSTAINABILITY AND ADVOCACY PUT
YOUR RANGE COUNTY CHAPTER OF
THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS D. A. AT THE LARGEST
UP OF THE HAT PROFESSIONALS IN
THE NATION THE EIGHT HAD MADE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION AN
URGENT PRIORITY AND APPROACH
DECARBONISATION EXISTING
BUILDING. THROUGH THE READILY
AVAILABLE ELECTRIFICATION
TECHNOLOGIES SUCH AS HE TALKS.
I KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT
RESIDENTS AND TAKING HAVE
ALREADY BEGUN ASKING ARCHITECTS
THE STRATEGY TO DECARBONISE THE
EXISTING BUILDING STOCK. FOR
EXAMPLE IRVINE BECAME THE FIRST
CITY IN ORANGE COUNTY AND ONLY
THE THIRD CITY IN ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. TO COMMIT. TO
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
THIRTY. BUT HE THAT HE WHICH
HAD ME THE COME TO NEUTRALITY
NEEDS GUIDANCE AND STRATEGIES
FOR DECARBONISING EXISTING
BUILDING CALIFORNIA FIFTIES
URGING KERR LEADERSHIP FROM THE
STATE ON BASE TO INCENTIVIZE
AND STRATEGIZE THE
DECARBONISATION OF OUR EXISTING
BUILDINGS I HOPE THE
PRESENTATION EXPRESS AT THIS
HEARING ACTION FROM THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU PAY
ATTENTION ANTI Q. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ROSENBERGER HATER I
THINK YOU REALLY NEED TO GET
FISHING UP FINANCES LIKE
WILDLIFE IF YOU YOU HEAR ME.
OKAY AND. NEXT THAT WE WILL GO
TO A LINE OF EIGHT- SHE DOES
ISRAEL GO TO LINE OF TWENTY
YEAR LINE OF THE HE GOOD
AFTERNOON OF INTO CRUCIAL AREA
I'M AND HERKY A RETIRED JOHN
AND WEBER CHANGE NOW LOOKING
OPEN ON FIVE HUNDRED CAL
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL FOCUS
ON THE PUBLIC HOW EMERGENCY
CUENTA AND RELATED CLIMATE ARE
JEFF ABOUT. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE IN THE WEATHER ARE AT WEST
ABOUT YES ON THE TWO PRICE DR
FOURTH JEFF DID IF THEY'RE THAT
A BASELINE SHE AND IT WAS
MENTIONED SEVEN DOLLARS A MONTH
WHICH IS A LOT OF IT ALONG WITH
MARCH PART THREE THAT THAT
BATES HE DESCRIBED BASED ON.
CALIFORNIA INCOME TAX WE MUCH
COMMOTION POSSIBLE ALSO ALONG
LINES OF DOCTOR PRESENTATION
TODAY I TO COME YOUR ATTENTION
TO THE FOOT RECORD ALLEGES THE
CASE STRATEGY FOR EQUITABLE GAS
WHICH IS FROM THE BUILDING
PATIENT CO ON HAS BEEN APPROACH
OF HOW HOW SECTOR FOR BY NAME
WHAT TWENTY THE GAS TANKERS.
THAT LOWER THE SISTER WIVES
ACROSS IT WILL LEADING NOBODY
AND PARTICULARLY LONG CONNECT
SO TAKE A DEEP TO BE THE FIRST
TO BE HOLDEN ABOUT FOR THE END
CALL OF THE CURRENT CAP
INTEREST. THIS APPROACH TO HOLD
RECORD BACK USING BECAUSE I
WHAT ALL ALLOW TO NORTH COULD
AND IN AIR TRUST WITH THE
HIGHEST BURDEN FOR DISEASE. AIR
POLLUTION AND IT COULD POP
BECOME WITH HOLLISTER APPROACH
INCLUDING WHETHER IT'S A
INFORMATION AND ALREADY A SHORT
HEALTH HAZARDS LIKE LATTIMORE
I'M SORRY YOUR APPROACH I'M
SORRY YOUR YOUR TO MY IS BY PRE
YOUR YOUR OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT TO HER YOUR WATER
LINE FORTY YOU KNOW I IS OPEN
PLEASE GO SH GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
TO COMMENT MY IS ANY GRAB AND I
WORK THE LOCAL OFFICE OF ARM
AND ENDED NON WORKING TOWARD A
LOW CARBON FUTURE CALIFORNIANS
SPEND ABOUT 90% OF OUR TIME
INSIDE BUILDINGS. WITH WELFARE
NO BECAUSE THEY HAVE AIR
POLLUTION OUTSIDE. TO ENSURE
THAT THE ERROR BREEDING INSIDE
OUR HOMES AND BUSINESSES IT'S
CLEAN AND SAFE. NATURAL GAS AND
HYDROGEN COMBUSTION AND IT'S
HARMFUL POLLUTANTS LIKE
NITROGEN DIOXIDE IN AND AROUND
OUR HOME THE ONLY VIABLE
PATHWAY Q. SAFE AND HEALTHY
BUILDINGS IT BY ELECTRIFIED OUR
PLAN IS BOB HYDROGEN MAY PLAY A
ROLE IN A CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE I
DID NOT BELONG ARE BUILDING.
EFFICIENT ELECTRIC APPLIANCES
AND EQUIPMENT ARE AVAILABLE FOR
INSTALLATION TODAY MANY STUDIES
SHOW THAT BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION IS THE LEAST
COSTLY PATH AFTER GETTING
BUILDING POLLUTION. HYDROGEN OF
COSTLY AND IT'S FIVE TIMES LESS
EFFICIENT IF YOU LOOK HOME
COMPARED TO ELECTRIC HEAT PUMP
ANY STATE SUPPORT WRITER AND
ANOTHER BASED ENERGY STAR STATE
SHOULD FOCUS ONLY ON THE HARD
TO ELECTRIFY FACTORS LIKE
INDUSTRY I DO NOT HAVE THEIR-
CARP AND MARKET READY SOLUTIONS
AVAILABLE LIKE BUILDING YOU.
CALIFORNIA HAS AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS AND NOW IS THE
TIME TO ACT. CALIFORNIA BUT
COMMIT TO A LONG TERM STRATEGY
TO ELECTRIFY EXISTING BUILDING
STOCK WE NEED TO CREATE A
POLICY THAT INVESTMENT TO
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION FROM GAS
TO ELECTRIC APPLIANCES ACTUALLY
SUPPORTING AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES. I URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO PRIORITIZE THE
ELECTRIFICATION NUMBER BUILDING
FACTOR AND MAKE A CLEANER
HEALTHIER BUILDINGS FOR ALL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
AMERICAN FROM LINE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS THE SONG
WHICH ARE JUSTICE- THANKS SO
MUCH CHAIR HOLDEN AND JERRY
VOTES FOR SOMETHING THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT COMMITTEE
HEARING- I'LL TRY TO KEEP MY
THREE POINTS REALLY QUICK SO MY
FIRST ONE IS JUST. YOU KNOW
FOLLOWING UP ON THANKING YOU
FOR HAVING THIS HEARING I ALSO
REALLY WANT TO URGE SORT OF A
PARADIGM SHIFT IN THE WAY WE
THINK ABOUT AND TALK ABOUT THE
EXISTING BUILDING THE CAR. FROM
A COST TO INVESTMENT- YES
UPGRADING ELECTRIFY EXISTING
BUILDING STOCK IS EXPENSIVE BUT
WE SHOULD FEEL REALLY HELPFUL
ABOUT THE INVESTMENT NEEDED IN
THIS FRONT HERE EMPLOYING
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS IN HIGH
ROAD JOBS. DELIVERING
COMFORTABLE RESILIENT AND
POLLUTION FREE HOMES AND
SCHOOLS IS ONE OF THE MOST
UPLIFTING ASPECTS OF THE CLEAN
ENERGY TRANSITION. AND I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE HAS AN ENORMOUS
WILL TO PLAYING. COMMUNICATING
THAT VISION TO THE PUBLIC AND
THEN ALSO THIS INVESTMENT OF
COURSE HAS TO START WITH LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. TO MAKE
THIS AN OPPORTUNITY DELIVER
JUSTICE- ESPECIALLY THE
COMMUNITIES WHO ALREADY FACE
ENERGY BURDENS AND OCCUPY THE
JOB IS THE MOST INEFFICIENT
HOMES. SISTER MCALLISTER SAID
LIKE THE TRANSITION PORT TO BE
EFFECTIVE NEEDS TO FOCUS ON
BEING BOTTOM UP AND MY SECOND
POINT IS THAT STRATEGIC
DECOMMISSIONING OF THE DOCTORS
TRADITION SYSTEM AS YOU HEARD
IT IS IMPERATIVE IN THE LEAGUE
ASML'S COFFEE LINE TO THE GAS
SYSTEM CAN BE A TRIPLE WIN FOR
CLIMATE RATES AND COMMUNITIES
SO THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
REALLY AGGRESSIVELY PURSUE THE
STRATEGY IN ADDITION TO
LEVERAGING OPPORTUNITIES
RIPARIAN COOLING WITH HEATING
EYES JERRY BUSES BILL. SET UP
TO DO AND FINALLY. I VALUE ALL
TO PLEASE BE ON GUARD ABOUT
HYDROGEN WE SHOULDN'T BE
SPLITTING RESOURCES PUTTING
EXPENSIVE GREEN HYDROGEN. IN A
SYSTEM THAT WE NEED TO BE
DECOMMISSIONING THE SIMPLE FACT
OF THE HYDROGEN CAN ONLY BE
HANDLED A REALLY SMALL VOLUMES
IN THE JOB SYSTEM WHICH HAVE
LIMITED CARBON SAVINGS NO AIR
POLLUTION BENEFIT. AND ALL THAT
STUFF FAR GREATER EXPENSE
ELECTRIFICATION SAYS DAVID
GREEN HYDROGEN FOR CLEANING
SECTORS WE CAN'T ELECTRIFY LIKE
SHIPPING AND FERTILISER
PRODUCTION. I PROMISE THERE'S
NO NEED TO LET IS YOUR TWO
HUNDRED AND STATE SCHOOL BOARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MODERATOR FROM
MODERATOR- I COUNT TWELVE. ARE
THERE ADDITIONAL CALLERS ON THE
LINE IN A SETTLEMENT HOW MANY
WE HAVE SEVEN. IN Q. SEVEN Q.
OKAY WELL THEN LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER AND WE'LL SORT
OF FREEZE IT AT THE SENATE
THANK YOU OVER LINE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR HOLDEN CARE REVERSE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND TODAY FOR
CENTERS MY NAME IS CHRIS MARTIN
RICKETT SUMMER REGISTER
ARCHITECT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND PRACTITIONER
HERE IN LOS ANGELES I WORK FOR
A OFFICE TO FOCUS NOT PORTABLE
HOUSING AND- AND WHAT I FAMILY
HOUSING. I ALSO SERVE AS THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE ON THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE AMERICAN
INSTITUTE OF. THE AMERICAN
INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTS HERE IN
LOS ANGELES THIS YEAR HAS BEEN
VERY CHALLENGING WE HAVE TO
CONDEMN ACT WE HAD. HEAT WAVES
WE'VE HAD FIREWORKS AND I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF AND IN
SUPPORT OF ELECTRIFYING THE
EXISTING BUILDING STOCK AND
REYES OUT FOSSIL FUELS MANY OF
YOU MAY BE AWARE BUT LOS
ANGELES IS SITTING IN ONE OF
THE BIGGEST IF NOT THE BIGGEST-
WELL IN THE UNITED STATES WILL
BECOME OIL WELL WE HAVE. A
MASSIVE PRODUCTION WITH- FUEL
TERRORIST PLOTS THE POOL OF
MANY HEALTH IN OPPOSITION AND
COST OF ELECTRIFIED THE
BUILDING STOCK BUT WE ALSO HAVE
TO FOCUS ON THE HEALTH OF
PEOPLE IN SPECIALLY IN THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
WHAT IS THE COST DO YOU PUT IN
THERE HEALTH NEELAM CANNOT
SUPPORT SO IT'S THE STATE'S TO
ALSO SUPPORT THAT YOU WITNESS
HERE INSTANT LEARNING
CALIFORNIA PROBABLY SEE A LOT
OF SMOKE COMES IN THE PICTURES
OF LAKE TAHOE THIS MORNING SIX
RESET WE NEED TO FIGHT AGAINST
TRYING CHANGE CONSORTIA COURT
THEIR COLLECTIVE IN THE CARBON
BUILDING STOCK THANK YOU THANK
YOU X. BIGGER THANK YOU MEXICO
I KNOW FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU- SHARON AND ALSO- TERRY THE
STRIPPER HAVING CERTAIN- MY
NAME'S MCALESTER OKLAHOMA COURT
AGREED CURRENT HEALTHCARE
CORPORATION A WORLD LEADER IN
HEATING VENTILATION AIR
CONDITIONING. TO KEEP THE
STREAK WHICH SAW THE NEXT
TECHNICAL WORK COMMITTED TO
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND THE
HARMONIZATION OF OUR EQUIPMENT-
AND WE BELIEVE THAT HE BONDS
HAVE GREAT PROMISE- FOR MOST
SECTORS MOST BUILDING TYPES- WE
DO WANT TO KIND OF CARRY OUT
RIGHT NOW AT THIS TIME. BUDGET
OFFERINGS ARE AVAILABLE FOR ALL
CLIMATE ZONES CALIFORNIA OR ALL
BUILDINGS INTO THAT AND WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK ON
DEVELOPING THIS TECHNOLOGY- AND
JUST YOU KNOW WILL CONTINUE TO
BE A SOURCE OF LEGISLATURE
AMERICANS ARE VITAMINS TCM ALL-
TESTIFY FURTHER- WE ALSO WANT
TO ADD THAT CODES AND STANDARDS
MATTER. AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE'RE PUSHING TECHNOLOGY WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT CODES
AND STANDARDS KEEP UP AS WE'VE
EXPERIENCED IN THE FOOTER
INSIDE- YOU WE'VE GONE DEEPER
WITH A RECRUITER- GWP REDUCTION
BUT WE CANNOT BRING THOSE TO
MARKET IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THE COLORS ARE NOT UP TO DATE.
THE EXTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE
TO ELEVATE THIS INDUSTRY MOVING.
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
STEVE GOODMAN THE I'M A
PRINCIPAL WITHOUT CONSULTING
ENGINEERING FIRM IN SAN
FRANCISCO NAME GIVEN ABOVE
WHAT- SIXTY FIVE YEAR OLD
COMPANY HEADQUARTERED IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- I'VE
PERSONALLY SPENT THE PAST FIVE
YEARS IMMERSED IN THE
CHALLENGES OF DESIGNING
DECARBONIZE. BUILDINGS IN
CALIFORNIA- SO I'M A BOOTS ON
THE GROUND PRACTITIONER AND I
WANT TO ADDRESS SOME THINGS I
HEARD TODAY- BY WAY OF
INTRODUCTION ALL SAT ON THE
PRINCIPAL INVESTIGATOR FOR THE-
DESIGN PROFESSIONALS PRACTICE
CHI DECEIT. TO DECARBONISATION
OF THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT THAT'S
BEING PUBLISHED BY THE WILLIAM
J. WORKING FOUNDATION. AND
FUNDED BY GOOGLE MICROSOFT THE
AIA CALIFORNIA COUNCIL AND
OTHERS. I'M ALSO A MEMBER THE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION TASK
FORCE OF THE AMERICAN SOCIETY
OF HEATING REFRIGERATION AND
AIR CONDITIONINGENGINEERS.
WHICH WILL CONVENE IN APRIL OF
THIS YEAR TO PROVIDE LEADERSHIP
FROM WITHIN THE ENGINEERING
COMMUNITY ON HOW TO DECARBONISE
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT SO I TRY
TO DO THIS NOT ONLY AS A
CALIFORNIA PRACTITIONER BY TALK
TO PEOPLE ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
ABOUT THIS PROBLEM. AND
CHALLENGE- I CAN SEE THAT 70%
OF MY FRM'S CURRENT PROJECTS
ARE ALL ELECTRIC BUILDINGS- AND
WE DO ALL DIFFERENT BUILDING
TYPES STUDENT HOUSING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MARKET RATE
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING COLLAPSE
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES. THERE IS
NO TECHNICAL LIMITATION TO WHAT
HOW WE ELECTRIFIED BUILDINGS.
EXISTING BUILDINGS MARCH TO A
DIFFERENT DRUMMER- WHILE MY
FIRM DOES ADAPTIVE REUSE OF
EXISTING BUILDINGS AND WE DO
SORT OF WHOLESALE GOT IT
REPLACED. OF INFRASTRUCTURE
EXISTING BUILDINGS I CAN TELL
YOU NOT A SINGLE ONE OF OUR
CURRENT PROJECTS. IT'S AN
EXISTING BUILDING UPGRADE.
CONVERTING FROM GAS TO ELECTRIC
SYSTEMS. SO IN ORDER TO CONVERT
ENOUGH EXISTING BUILDINGS FAST
ENOUGH WE REQUIRE REGULATORY
INTERVENTION. PROMULGATING THE
CARBONIZATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
EXISTING BUILDINGS- THERE WAS A
QUESTION ASKED ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- ANIMAL I CAN'T SPEAK.
AS MUCH TO EXISTING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING I CAN TELL YOU THAT-
FIRST COMMITTEE HOUSING IN SAN
JOSE MERCY HOUSING IN SAN
FRANCISCO. ARE ALL HAVE ALL
BUILT AND ARE CURRENTLY
BUILDING MULTIPLE ALL ELECTRIC
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS.
THE NEW YORK TIMES REVAMPS WITH.
YOU'VE REACHED YOUR TWO MINUTES
OF I DO APPRECIATE YOUR IN WE
HAVE TAKEN NO ON YOUR THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER THANK YOU THAT A
COMBINED FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YES MY
NAME IS PETER TURNBULL FORMERLY
WITH P. GENIE RIGHT GET HERO
NET ENERGY WORK I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE THE CHAIRS AND
THE PANELISTS FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVEN'T
REALLY TALKED ABOUT MUCH ARE WE
TALKED ABOUT LEADING FINANCING
INCENTIVES RIGHT NAKED
MECHANISMS ALL DESIGNED FOR THE
EXISTING BUILDING. RECOLLECTED
WHAT WE REALLY NEED IN ADDITION
TO THESE THINGS. OUR TOOLS
RESEARCH ON NEW PIECES OF
EQUIPMENT NEW EQUIPMENT LINE UP
AND NEW PIXELATION THAT THAT
THAT CUT THE COST OF DOING
THESE RETRO FIT. THE CENTRAL
VALLEY PROJECT SET UP THE GENES
INVOLVED IN. SOMETHING LIKE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER DWELLING UNIT DIRECTOR
OKAY. THAT'S ONE NINE STARTER
DOESN'T NEED TO BE THAT WAY WE
GET RESEARCH EFFORTS THAT HAD
DROPPED THE COST AFFORDABLE
PAIR. OF REPORTS RAIDERS TODAY
USE ONE FOR THE ENERGY THEY USE
IN. NINETEEN SEVENTY AND THEY
DON'T COST MUCH TARGETED
RESEARCH AND FOLLOW AND BACK UP
BY WHAT DID THAT WE COULD WE
HAVE A TECHNICAL THE BILL AND
THOSE ARE GREAT START THANK YOU
TO BE MORE BY A OF TEN WHEN
THAT WILL STAY BUT MONEY IN
LONG RUN I'M STILL TARGETED
RESEARCH IN AT COST IT'S
SOMETHING WE HAVEN'T TALKED
ABOUT DESPERATELY DO THANK YOU
THANK YOU OUR NEXT SPEAKER
THANK YOU ARE COMPROMISED
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU
HAVE A TIME YOU. AND WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALLER IS
LINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HI GOOD
AFTERNOON TURNED REMEMBERS WARM
CALM ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
THIRTEEN LOCAL CHAPTERS AND
HALF MILLION MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS ACROSS THE STATE THE
REASON IPCC REPORT MADE IT
CLEAR THAT WE NEED MORE
AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE ACTION THE
URGENCY OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS
REQUIRES THAT WE IMPLEMENT
STRONGER MORE AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
POLICIES AND THAT INCLUDES
POLICIES THAT WILL HELP THE
STATE SHIFT. TO ALL ELECTRIC
EFFICIENT HOMES AND BUILDINGS
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. RECORD
BREAKING HEAT WAVE CLICK CLICK
ON THE TOP LEFT NONE THE FAMILY
SPONSORING A BIG SUBJECT GREEN
ELECTRICALLY PUMPED THE ONLY
TECHNOLOGY THAT. WOULD BE GREAT
AND THE KIND OF CRAZY ON
CALIFORNIA SURE REPUBLICAN
STATEWIDE BUT ONLY HOME IT WILL
BE THE ACT COOL OR TO REPLACE
THE BURNED OUT. ON. WE CAN
BUILD BECAUSE OF THE FEMALE
CLEAR THAT THAT JUST OF TO HAVE
ACHIEVE ICON ARE QUALITY COAL
NEXT WEEK MY COMMITTEE A LONG
TERM MARKET STRATEGY DIRECTOR
BY THE FIFTEEN BODY FAT THREE
THANK YOU FOR HER TO CHEN APPS
AND WE THAT THE START MUST
PRIORITIZE EQUITY BY MAIL
JUSTICE AND LOW INCOME INVOLVED
COMMUNITY AS THE THROUGHOUT THE
TRANSITION IN ADDITION WE MUST
CONTINUE REDUCE RELIANCE PUBLIC
FOR THE YOU CAN TO STOP THE
EXPANSION THE GAPS AND ALSO
PRODUCE A NEW JOB LOOK AT I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE TO
COMMENT ON THE BUT HAS CHANGED
WE- LOOK TOWARD TO WITH ALLEGE
AND EIGHTEEN ON THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS EXPECT HER THANK YOU
ANALYZE YOU CHAIR WILL COME MY
EIGHT YEAR IS- OPEN IT. BY
TWENTY UP THEY REMOVE THE YEAH
MY TWENTY EIGHT YEAR THERE'S
FROM TO YOU'LL HAVE TO RE QUEUE
HELLO SIR GO AHEAD. THE WAIT
OUT OF REACH YOU ARE YOU
HEARING ME NOW SO WE CAN HEAR
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD I SAW A
GHOST FINISH- WE REALLY NEED IS
VERY LOW WIDE- STOVES
REFRIGERATORS AND HE PLANS TO
STAY SEATED- EVEN THOUGH STILL
REFRIGERATOR COMBO SERMONS
THERMOELECTRIC COOLING PLATES
TAKEN THANKS ACTUALLY I A GOT A
FIVE HUNDRED WHAT IS STILL
WHICH S
ATE AND THEY CAN PUT DOWN THE
HUNTER WANTS TO RUN IT OFF A
HUNTER WHAT BATTERY CHARGER AND
GET A CUP MAYBE TWO. HUNDRED
WATT BATTERY CHARGING SYSTEMS
IN THAT'S ALL I CAN FOR IT I'M
REALLY LOW INCOME- I'LL HAVE
HOPE OF HER MORE OF ON HEALTH
ISSUES BUT I WANTED HOW IN THE
SHE I COULDN'T GO AHEAD PIPS
SOLAR AND OFF THE GRID IF I DO
IT ALSO AGREED I CAN AFFORD IT.
AND I REALLY WISH OF OFF THE
GRID WITH A LOUD LIKE A TINY
HOUSE WITH EXPERIMENTAL OFF
GRID SOLAR BATTERY CHARGER
SECOND STORY. AND WHATEVER ALL
OF THE CLIENTS WHO HAVE VERY
LITTLE WHILE SO I DON'T USE UP
MY BATTERY TO RUN OUT OF
ELECTRIC AND I THINK I CAN
MANAGING. I CAN ALWAYS ROUGH
ALWAYS GOT SOME OTHER. OTHER
WAYS LIKE HANGING SHINY
REFLECTIVE POTATO CHIP BAG
CURTAINS. ON THE WINDOWS THAT
CAN AND HE REDUCE THE SUNLIGHT
HEAT AND THE FOR. SHE BE OPEN
FROM THE TOP AND ACTUALLY I
DON'T EVEN USE A FREEZER
REFRIGERATOR REALLY WANT TO
PIECE A LITTLE PIECE OF LAND
WHICH I CAN GROW FOOD ON RIGHT
NEXT TO MY HOUSE SMALL HOUSE
LEAVING A LOT OF EXTRA LAND
FOR. TO GROW A GARDEN AND I
DON'T EVEN HAVE TO OPEN THE
REFRIGERATOR DURING THE PEAK
TIME AROUND DINNER TIME I DON'T
WANT TO OPEN MY REFRIGERATOR
TAKE THE STUFF OUT OF THE
GROUND IT'S- IT'S ALREADY WARM
AND PUT IT IN A PAN. AND BOIL
IT IT WAS A HUNDRED WHILE THE
STATE HOME THAT THAT ALSO ALSO
I SHOULD HAVE ONE ALSO OPERATE-
A REFRIGERATOR AT THE SAME TIME
THE STOVE ON TOP OR SURGERY- ON
THE BOTTOM AND I NEED SOME HELP
WITH GETTING A MAKING IT A MEET
THE BUILDING CODES AND BE
ALLOWED TO MAYBE GET A MORTGAGE
ON THE LAND WITHOUT HOUSES.
THEN I FOUND A TINY PIECE OF
LAND FOR AND EVERYTHING I CAN
TO CONTRACTORS WORK FOR YOU
THANK YOU YOU REACH YOUR TO
MAX. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND AGAIN WE ARE
TAKING NOTES ON EVERYONE WHO
MADE. COMMENTS TODAY- WE DO
APPRECIATE- MODERATOR MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WAS THE
LAST SPEAKER. YES ONE MORE TIME
INTO Q. MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TAKE THAT ONE. WE DID
SAY THAT WE WOULD CUT IT OFF
AFTER SEVEN BUT IF IT'S ONLY
ONE MORE LET THEM TELL ME ONE
MORE LET THEM PURSUE ARE BLIND
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. CAN YOU
HEAR ME OKAY YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREAT HI-
CHERRY HOLDEN CHEN WE BOTH MY
NAME IS IGOR TRACK OKAY FOR THE
RECORD I AM A MEMBER OF THE
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE BUT
SPEAKING IN MY PERSONAL
CAPACITY AND MY APOLOGIES FOR
COMPANIES AND I KEPT BEING TOP
TOPS Q. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY. THE
RECENT IPCC REPORT CONFIRMS
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE A CLASS OF
ACTION CONTRAST THE CLIMATE
CRISIS WHICH INCLUDES SWIFTLY
TRANSITIONING. TO ALL ELECTRIC
HOMES AND BUILDINGS TO THAT END
WITH MOST RECENT BILL CALLED A
CALIFORNIA ENERGY HAS MADE IT
CLEAR THAT FOLLOW AFTER
BUILDING FOR CRITICAL TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY WELL I DO WANT TO KNOW
AT EVEN WITH THE SUCCESS- OF
THEIR AMENDMENTS TO TITLE
TWENTY FOUR THAT POP A WEEK AND
A HALF AGO THAT CAN ONLY BE
MADE POSSIBLE IF THE CPUC ALLOW
HE ARE LIKE ROOFTOP SOLAR AND
STORAGE TO CONTINUE TO BE MRE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE NOT
TO LAUGH AND AT THAT POINT I
CORD BUT INTEREST DR CLARK'S
CONCERNS IS A NEW CLIPART OUT
BY DOCTOR CLACK ACTIVELY WITH
SOME CLUBS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
WOULD BE GLAD TO DROP A COPY OF
IT IN YOUR OFFICE OR EMAIL IT
TO YOU AND IT ACTUALLY SELLS
THAT IS A SAVINGS. I LOVE ALL
SAVINGS TO CONSUMERS AGAIN TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA A
HUNDRED TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS
BUT MORE IT WILL STOP FOWLER
AND STORAGE. QUICKLY TAKING
HEAT WAVES IN ADVANCE WITH
HISTORICALLY COOLER CLIMATE
HAVE LEFT MILLIONS OF FAMILIES
WELL DOING AND ON STATE CAPTURE
COUNTERCLAIMS MADE BY THE GAS
INDUSTRY THE FINDINGS BEST
SEATS A. B. THIRTY TWO THIRTY
THREE POINT I'M SORRY OUT THAT
EVEN IF ARE IN MY ACCOUNT THE
CONCEPT IS ME YOU YOU'VE
REACHED FOR TWO MINUTES SO I
I'M APOLOGIZE FOR HAVING TO CUT
YOU OFF BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
KEEP EVERYONE GOALIE TO THE
MINUTES BUT WE DO TAKE YOUR
COMMENTS IN THE ISSUE ABOUT THE
AFFORDABILITY ACCESSIBILITY
THOSE CERTAINLY BEEN A THEME
THROUGH OF THE PUBLIC COMMENTS
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
MODERATOR THAT'S RIGHT WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE IN THAT- AND I ALSO
WANTED TO THANK ALL OF THOSE
WHO CALLED IN TO SHARE THEIR
PUBLIC COMMENT I THINK IT'S
VERY INSTRUCTIVE IN PUBLIC
HEARINGS LIKE THIS.
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS TO HAVE
INPUT FROM THE PUBLIC AND I WAS
VERY PLEASED THAT WE HAD THE
KIND OF ROBUST INTEREST IN THIS
TOPIC THAT DREW SO MANY. WHO
HAVE SUCH VALUE COMMENTS AND
THOUGHTS AND CERTAINLY CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW WE DECARBONISE ON OUR
EXISTING BUILDING STRUCTURE
INSTANCE STATURE. AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SHE SAID. BOB
LET ME JUST THANK OUR
PANELISTS- POPPING BACK UP I
WAS GOING TO. BE MISSED
FRIEDMAN YOU I GET THE PRICE
FOR HANGING IN THE LOGS BUT IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A GOOD
NUMBER OF OUR PALACE THAT ARE
STILL PRESENT AND I DO
APPRECIATE. FOR PERSONAL YOUR-
YOUR INSIGHT AND PERSPECTIVE
YOU'RE LEARNING THOUGHTS AROUND
THE SUBJECT- THE CONTRIBUTION
TO THIS ISSUE IS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED AND IT'S GOING TO
BE ON GOING. AND I THINK THAT
ALL OF YOUR COMMENTS REFLECTED
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF US. THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT NEEDS TO KIND OF GET-
INTEGRATED INTO OF PLANNING AND
TRANSITIONING AND DECARBONISING
OUR EXISTING BUILDING STOCK
STOCK. AND I JUST- A VERY
GRATEFUL THAT ALL OF YOU HAVE-
TAKEN THE TIME TO BE A PART OF
THIS PRESENTATION TODAY AND AS
YOU CAN HEAR FROM THE- PEOPLE
WHO CALL CALLED IN. A
AFFORDABILITY AND-
ACCESSIBILITY ARE TWO VERY
IMPORTANT. ISSUES THAT ARE OUT
THERE AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD
JUST ON ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF
DECARBONISATION AND MAKING THE
EFFECTIVE TRANSITION IT'S GOING
TO BE. A COST IS GOING TO BE
VERY MUCH A PART OF- THE
INGREDIENTS SO I. I THANK ALL
OF YOU- COMMISSIONER MCALLISTER
A THANK YOU FOR. THE THE TIME
YOU SHARED WITH DR QUIRK AND
HIS A QUESTIONS AND I THINK
THERE WAS MAYBE. A POINT OR TWO
THAT NEEDED TO BE FINALIZED BUT
IF I CAN ASK YOU TO- CHECK IN
WITH HIM- I. THINK HE WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT AND IF YOU
COULD YES IN THE CONTINUE YOUR
KERR SO I DON'T THINK- WE HAVE
TIME FOR ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
UNLESS THERE'S SOMETHING
PRESSING BASED ON WHAT YOU
HEARD ANYONE IF YOU WOULD LIKE.
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO JUST. GIVE
A ONE MINUTE- CLOTHES NOT
REQUIRED BUT- IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU FIND. BASED
ON WHAT YOU HEARD OR SOMETHING
THAT YOU FELT NEEDS TO GET OUT
THERE ON THE RECORD TODAY. FEEL
FREE TO- TO MAKE OUT A LAST
MINUTE CLOSE CHAIR I WOULD JUST
ADD A COUPLE OF VERY BRIEF
POINTS WE HAVE A GREAT PLATFORM
TO PROCEED FORWARD ON WE HAVE
AN INCREDIBLE COMMUNITY OF THE
KNOWLEDGEABLE PEOPLE WE ARE
MANY OF THEM IN THE COMMENTS
SECTION WE HAVE SEVERAL ON THIS
PANEL- AND- THINGS LIKE THAT-
PROJECTS AT AT A- SMALL TO
MEDIUM SCALE THEY'RE ALREADY
OUT THERE. IS A REALLY GOOD
BUILDING RETROFIT PROGRAM IN
THE DISTANT PAST MUSIC AND THE
COACHELLA VALLEY- THAT THE AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
SOUTH COAST IS FUNDING- THAT IS
REALLY SHOWING GREAT SUCCESS
FOR EXAMPLE THAT IS A PLATFORM
FOR SCALE. WE HAVE A
BENCHMARKING PROGRAM THAT
COVERS OUR MULTI FAMILY HOMES
AND ARE NOT RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET. WE HAVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION AND WE CAN TAKE
THAT TO THE NEXT STEP- THE NEXT
STAGE BUT WITH SOME BUILDING
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS PERHAPS
BUT CERTAINLY- TARGETING
PROGRAMS TO THE BUILDINGS THAT
THE BENCHMARKING PROGRAM IS
SHOWING. ARE THE LEAST
EFFICIENT. AND SO WE HAVE A LOT
OF TOOLS JUST TO GET THOSE TWO
EXAMPLES AT OUR DISPOSAL TO
TARGET OUR EXISTING BUILDINGS
AND IT REPLICATE THE SUCCESS SO
IT IS GOING TO TAKE RESOURCES
IT IS GONNA TAKE PLANNING AND
CONCERTED EFFORT. BUT WE ARE A
STATE THAT KNOWS HOW TO DO THIS
AND SO WE HAVE A TRACK RECORD.
OF BEING ABLE TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON MARKETS AND ONCE WE
DO THAT WE GET A CONSISTENT
LONG TERM VIEW OF WHAT OUR
POLICY IS GOING TO BE THE
MARKETPLACE DOES PICK IT UP AND
RUN WITH IT. WE'VE SEEN THAT
TIME AND TIME AGAIN IT DOES
TAKE THAT CONCERTED MESSAGING
AND AN INTENTION PROJECTING
FORWARD FOR A DECADE OR MORE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND THE REST OF THE OF THE
LEGISLATURE- ON ADVANCING THESE
IDEAS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
LEADERSHIP. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP SIERRA LET'S
LET'S DISCUSS GREAT MALES MATH
AYE JUST WANTED TO ECHO
COMMISSIONER MCALLISTER ON ON
PLANNING AND BUSINESS CERTAINTY
AND CONSISTENCY FOR
MANUFACTURERS. THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT- CERTAINLY
ON BEHALF OF A. O. SMITH- WERE
READY TO- AND BRACES STEP UP TO
THE CHALLENGE AND ARE WORKING
WITH OUR- OUR FRIENDS AND OUR
FRIENDS. AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND AMONGST OTHERS-
BUT BUSINESS CERTAINTY IS KEY
FOR US SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT OUR PRODUCT ENGINEERING
AND ROAD MAPPING- FITS THE
MARKET- BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY WE DO SELL TO CUSTOMERS
AND- WE NEED THAT DEMANDED. OF
CERTAINTY IN THE REGULATORY
SPACE AND THANKS AGAIN FOR.
HAVING US AS A PART OF THIS
HEARING. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT. AND IT YES PLEASE. IF
IT'S ALL RIGHT- GERALD I'D SAY
JUST SAY ONE QUICK THING- I WAS
REALLY STRUCK IN THE COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS THAT YOU'RE RIVAS
ASKED. ABOUT EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT WHEN- A
HOMEOWNER IS CONSIDERING.
GETTING AIR CONDITIONING GET A
HEAT PUMP IS A NO BRAINER TO
KEEP DOES TYPICALLY WILL GO
AND CALL HOME. AND IN ADDITION
TO THE EXTREME HEAT CONCERNS
THAT YOU'RE RIVAS EXPRESSED I
THINK IT'S ALSO REALLY
IMPORTANT EMPHASIZED THAT.
MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION MIGHT
ALSO ALLOW FOR A HOME TO HAVE
MUCH IMPROVED AIR QUALITY THAT
ARE PROTECTED RESIDENTS FROM
SMOKE IMPACTS AND THAT'S
BECOMING INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE TO BE
ADDRESSED IN CALIFORNIA. WE
NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT HOW
TO BUILD TIGHTER HOMES THAT
WILL BE ENERGY EFFICIENT. AS WE
DO AS WE SHUT THE WINDOWS ON A
HOT SUMMER DAY WHEN YOU'RE
SMOKING OUTSIDE WE'RE GONNA
NEED AIR CONDITIONING. AND DOT
SYSTEM HAS THE POTENTIAL WITH A
HIGH QUALITY AIR FILTERS TO
REALLY PROTECT ITS RESIDENTS
ESPECIALLY KIDS RIGHT AND
WOMEN. AND SENIOR CITIZENS FROM
THE IMPACTS OF SMOKE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR PUTTING
A FINE POINT ON THAT- TOPIC
BROUGHT UP BY. THE CHAIR- I
WANT TO JUST THINK AGAIN ALL OF
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND BEFORE
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA
SO- AS WE MOVE FOR A TOWARDS
THE JOURNEY I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A MOMENT. TO RECOGNIZE
JAMES PARK WHO'S OUR DOCTOR
PARK WHO IS OUR- SCIENCE FELLOW
FOR THIS YEAR AND MANY OF YOU
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY SHE WAS PART
OF. SHE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PUTTING ON THIS HEARING
ORGANIZING THAT ANY TOUCHING
BASES WITH ALL OF YOUR OFFICES
AND SO I JUST WANTED TO
RECOGNIZE HER- THIS IS- HER
LAST HEARING AS A SCIENCE
FELLOW. WE KNOW THIS IS GOING
TO BE- AN INCREDIBLE LEADER IN
THIS SPACE- IN OR OUTSIDE OF
THIS BUILDING AND WE LOOK
FORWARD AND OR OR- PRIVILEGED
TO HAVE A PROGRAM THAT BRINGS
US SUCH. TALENTED PEOPLE TO
BECOME PART OF THE SCIENCE OF
ENERGY AND UTILITY ON THE
MARKET PLACE AND SO WE JUST
WANT TO GIVE HER-
CONGRADULATIONS WERE GREAT
YEAR. SHE HAD- COVERT AS OUR
FIRST YEAR AND SO THAT WAS NOT
FUN DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO.
INTERACT QUITE AS MUCH BUT-
SHE'S JUST BEEN. AMAZING AND WE
THANK HER FOR HER LEADERSHIP
AND HER ROLE WITH THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU AND WITH
THAT- WITH THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED. IT.